the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
Lake of the grantchester is underway at
the super United rapid and Blitz in
sawgrave Croatia some of the world's
strongest Grandmasters have assembled to
Showcase their rapid and Blitz prowess
in the capital city polish Superstar Jan
kirstoff Duda started off hot winning
his first two games but stumbled in the
third round against Richard Rapport
dudas misstep allowed former world
champion viswanathon Anand to LeapFrog
him for sole lead ending his impressive
day with back-to-back wins despite
assisting his first place rival Rapport
is tied per second and in Hot Pursuit
will Anand maintain his narrow lead day
two of Rapid chess coming up next
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back chess fans to day two of
the super United rapid and Blitz held
here in Zagreb Croatia we started it in
front of the National Theater a landmark
here in the center of Zagreb yesterday
the players put on a great show over the
chessboard what will they bring in
today's rounds let's go to the studio
and find out
the grandchild returns to Croatia it is
rapid and Blitz action with the greatest
players in the world our live coverage
from the Saint Lucia's club and Zagreb
starts right now
hello and welcome everyone thank you for
joining us I'm International
and I'm here with Grandmaster yasu
sarawan nassi it was a wonderful day
yesterday it was so much fun exactly you
and Miro calling all the action that was
great I I loved it day one started with
a blast and Thrills and Spills Galore if
you like chess you're gonna love this
rapid and Blitz and it was the inspiring
play of Juan viswanathon the tiger of
Madras that thrilled me but let's take a
look at the standings after day one
let's take a look we have a soul leader
the legend viciana with Five Points
closely following with plus one score
Magnus Carlson Jan Christoph Duda and
Richard report nice trailing pack I must
say and with 50 we have Fabiano caruana
and Ivan sarich and tell us about the
format nasty we have a 10 player round
robin tournament in the rapid time
control is 25 plus 10. in Blitz it's
five plus two in the rapid the scoring
system is double scoring two points for
win and one for a draw in the blitz it's
the traditional scoring system and their
no drafters allowed and our schedule
uh today we start day two of the rapid
and tomorrow we have the last round of
last day of rapid and then two more days
of Blitz and on Sunday playoffs if
necessary excellent and Miro wow what a
day uh it was yesterday for chess it's
great to have you in studio and tell us
what you found inspiring about yesterday
thanks siasa greetings people at home
watching this coverage uh well it was a
it was a hot warm-up day if I may say so
right some people are still looking to
find their written their shape in the
tournament uh Magnus Carlsen will number
one admitted that he's happy with the
results of the first day and there was
one man who seemingly needed no warm-up
whatsoever
the oldest the most experienced and it
turned out the most energetic player of
our field started with a draw against
ferrugia where he had a chance to win in
the game and then followed it up with
two back-to-back wins on five out of six
the leader visionand and let's not
forget the field he is leading it's a
very very strong tournament out of
world's top 10 rapid players we have
five present here it's Magnus Carlsen
young Christian Builder racial report
Vision himself and Fabiano caruana are
in a World's rapid top 10. right and as
we are and as we are waiting for the
second day of Rapid to begin let's talk
to Anastasia Christian uh crew members
in Croatia as our group
thanks miroy and welcome back chess fans
to day two of the super United rabbit
and Blitz held here in Zagreb Croatia
and what an amazing start to this event
we had in yesterday's rounds a lot of
Fighting Chess and Miro you highlighted
viswanathan just an incredible player
but of course I'm also having my eyes on
two very impressive players a wild card
Magnus Carlson and a full tour
participant Jan shished off Duda who
actually had a great time and a great
tournament in Poland as well you
remember that last game between each
other to determine who's going to win uh
Poland grandchester leg and that was
just an incredible display but I have to
say Magnus impressed yesterday he didn't
impressed in Poland in day one but
yesterday he started off blazing hot
with a victory in round one against the
youngster only 17 years of age uh Donna
maraju cash and after that draw against
Ivan
but I have to say from a position of
strength he definitely had a great
chance to win that game against a young
neponia she and of course Duda just left
it where he just picked it up where he
left it off in Poland he's playing just
amazing chess he played well in Dubai as
well in global chess league and started
off with two victories against janepo
miyashi and Ali Reza firusha
unfortunately for him and by the way he
had a winning position in game three
against Richie report as well he lost
that one but he's definitely showing
great strength in this competition in
day one Anastasia what picked up your
eye actually Christian I really worry
about the world championship Challenger
Yani bonusi of course he's one of the
best players in the world when we speak
about rapid and Blitz and also classical
chess but you know lately he doesn't
have really good results starting from
the match and then in Romania he didn't
show the best ones and also then later
in Dubai he finished the tournament with
minus two so here he also suffers after
day one he lost the game against
Yankovic and Magnus but still you know I
saw him today at the breakfast and he
was asking me please tell me how to win
one game in a row and I was just
laughing I said if I knew there is a
recipe it's really hard to say something
here yeah so actually I just also wanted
to tell you that to tell to our
followers that we have a really great
location here in Zagreb we are quite
near to the center of the city to the
downtown and many players that take
advantage of it and have a nice walk to
the weather is great and I also had one
and made a few nice videos which you can
all watch in our Instagram and Facebook
and Twitter social media accounts so
please everybody don't forget to follow
us and you will you will find lots of
extra material there and sometimes if
you're one of the lucky ones you might
see Magnus Carlsen strolling around the
city center of zagreba I actually saw
him yesterday I was having dinner with a
friend and Magnus just passed by with
his headphones over his years he was
listening to his podcasts
I did not no I did not maybe next time I
play soccer with him but definitely
everybody's having a lot of fun here but
we're ready to start the games and start
the action guys back to you in St Louis
thank you Anastasia and thank you
Christian sounds like you guys are
having a lot of fun there in Zagreb and
Nasi do the honors for our audience and
tell them what they can expect in the
round four pairings that's take a look
exciting round four we have Magnus cross
and playing Fabiano Carlos wow stop
right there you had me at the Magnus
versus Fabi what a way to start round
four uh the tournament leader viciana is
playing Ivan sarich he's a Duda playing
lupulasco go cash playing Rapport and he
promised his face in ferrous fantastic
and they're going to be fighting very
hard and what they're what are they
fighting for they're fighting for a lot
of money there is total of 175
000 in prizes and the first place winner
is going to get forty thousand dollars
second place thirty thousand Thirty
twenty five thousand very nice price
fund all the way down to 10th and final
place of seven thousand dollars you win
clear first you get a grand chest tour
bonus point of one uh getting 13 points
the player at the end of the tour with
the most grandchester points will get
the title of grantchester champion as
well as a hundred thousand dollar cash
bonus as the players are taking their
seats round four we see Ivan sarich
there playing against our tournament
leader Rishi and none with the black
pieces it's gonna be very interesting to
see if Anan can maintain his lead today
exactly he started so nicely and when
vishy is in that groove of his that he
gets uh wow he just looks uh Imperial as
yeah he can be unstoppable yeah players
are filing in but it really it was
surprising Mira when you were talking
about you know the strength of this
tournament and how all the players in
the event that are in the top ten I'm
thinking to myself how can ferrugia
and Napo not being the top ten
there's too many players in the top ten
I mean if you can include farouja in
that boat
what's going on Mira all righty I said
well perhaps it has something to do with
uh latest results which were
underwhelming for both uh well rather
funny
most part and ferruja well you never
know I mean he can have one good
tournament and he off you go with extra
100 evil points right he's still young
he's well established and we look at him
as like one of the guys who are always
there but let's not forget the guy is
only 20.
exactly and I do believe we're waiting
for the chief of staff of the Croatian
Prime Minister uh and I can't even
pronounce his name I'll try to do your
best nasiva this one
you did it it's an humor uh it will be
making the ceremonial opening ceremonial
first move uh as we get round four
underway and again yesterday some really
Thrills and Spills and you were
mentioning that Magnus Carlson game
against Yvonne saritch that could easily
have seen Magnus up ended
here we go and again this is the chief
of staff of the Prime Minister
zeronimer furcar pet
s
and better known as the chief of
Staffordshire
very very nice when we get the political
support of the countries hosting the
events very nice
and as far as Magnus and Fabi are
concerned Amira what are you expecting
from these two illustrious players uh
wow and English
and English as you can see right if it
was a opening question then you say to
yourself well D to D4 by the way is a
little bit surprising yes right it's
very very principle it's always feels
like you know this game is something
special doesn't matter maybe these guys
will be playing next time or not the
next time but you know
in their 70s and we would still be ah
okay that's that's Magnus and Fabi
playing
um the Fabiana just played Knight what's
good
I'm in a natural move uh ever seen and I
have played this system as white myself
and I mean nobody has ever played in
this position against me
yeah I mean Knight E4 is fairly standard
castles uh everybody has played but
Knight A5 I would consider my team also
but yeah Knight E5 believe it or not but
there is a game there is a game in the
database played by you'd be surprised
Sergey rublevsky who was a very very
decent player back in the day I mean
probably still is it's now that he's
mostly coaching right it was one game
when a Grandmaster level worn by Sergey
rublevsky so Knight A5 even though it
looks weird we have to admit is is a
theoretical move
okay uh how does the engine regard that
move by the way
engine the engine's not impressed
uh well well actually now after some
thoughts engine turns to like Knight A5
interesting to like it I like it yeah
and white has to play Queen D3 otherwise
he slightly worse believe it or not so
maybe the movie is not the best but the
fact that it puts pressure on white very
early on right and the fact that Magnus
started the thing so he might be not
familiar with this one that's a that's
an interesting twist as early as move
six yeah to actually get uh Magnus out
of his opening book that's some some
trick clearly Fabi has analyzes with his
super computer and right Nelson A5 is a
decent move especially in the rapid I
you know I'm continually astounded by
the opening ideas that players come out
with Knight A5 would not have been on my
Horizon at all I also know notice in the
game of Vichy Anand Ivan sarich okay
very standard night or and queen D3
that's really quite quite rare yeah a
Twist I mean everybody has played so
many uh moves here whether it be Bishop
E3 Bishop G5 Bishop E2 G3
Rook G1 hello a2a4 F2 F4 so many moves
Queen D3 rather rare one and then as far
as I'm concerned E7 E6 Queen G3 okay
that's not been anywhere near
uh anything I know at all B5 A3 to stop
B4 Knight takes E4 Bishop B7 Bishop D3
and I would assume Knight to D7 of
course this queen is putting annoying
pressure and you don't get to play
nicely Bishop E7 but Knight D7 preparing
Knight C5 tickling I think vicious
preparing to Castle short okay let's do
it
let's do it and I'm assuming after
Knight C5 to just defend the pawn okay
one okay it's just hard for black to
develop the king side except I've seen
so often let's say I play Bishop E7 I
have seen so often that a lot of
Sicilian players are very happy to just
lose the pawn
and a castle now I'm not one of those
who's ready to sacrifice my pawns but
Meryl I think you'll agree with me that
there have been so many games where this
Pawn sacrifice is so I would call it
typical please jump in uh right you're
absolutely right yes sir the pawn on G7
well to sacrifice the pun on G7 is well
often a reaction of black to this
position of Queen on G3 speaking of
Queen G3 and the whole line starting
with Queen D3 Queen D3 is a rare line
but by night of Standards you still find
more than 140 games like 140 four games
to be exact in the database
but the very next move so Queen D3
I think is well just to cause some
confusion and then people usually
continue with like A4 or Bishop E2 doing
something standard but after Queen G3
you only have two games in the database
both by the way one by black so it
doesn't have a very good reputation
statistically
B5 A3 Bishop B7 Bishop D3 we still
follow one of the games uh Grandmaster
games from the game from 2014 Knight to
D7 Castle shorts still still in there
still in there so well computer is not
impressed slightly famous black but
that's I think that's pretty much always
the case in the night of interestingly
right up to the point when white gets an
decisive attack
so a computer really likes those
positional benefits uh Knight of uh you
know those flexible night of setups
offer right uh turning our attention to
the game I of good cash and Richie uh
you never really know what you're going
to get when Richard Rapport is on the
other side of the board you open up one
E4 and you just kind of hold your breath
and what does he do today he goes for a
night off no he goes for the class
classical uh four nights uh Rouser
Bishop G5 Bishop D7 and this is a move I
want to say that Drea have really
popularized Bishop D7 and this early
Rook C8 you're not playing E7 E6 and
you're not playing G7 G6 and Richie
following
Queen A5
Bishop D2 because I'm more used to
seeing F4 right exactly F2 F4 I think is
the standard but Bishop to D2 and Marrow
jump in and tell us what the theoretical
what's
what theory tells us about this position
uh wow
I've got some that will you know it's a
rare case when I've got some like my own
opinion on this line because if you if
you search the database for the players
who used to play this line and of course
you've mentioned dreyf and I think there
will be some other names but you can
find me as well so I used to play this
black yes I know a thing or two about
this and Bishop D2 indeed is not the
most popular but the thing is after F4
black usually cares with Rook takes C3
sacrifice exactly and this leads to
either Queens exchange and the Very in
my opinion very sound positional
compensation for black so it's a pawn
for an exchange plus you know a
structure and so on and so on that's
well in my opinion is perfectly playable
or there is another option you can take
with the pawn and then it leads to very
very messy position of the E5 Queen goes
to C4 D5 then Bishop A3 check and it's
very very sharp
so by playing Bishop D2 you kind of
limit limit the risk in a way so that's
right if your opponent has outprepared
you and you still insist on playing some
sort of slow well not not so slow but
positional Sicilian so to speak instead
of those sharp complications exactly so
Bishop did D2 as you say avoiding the
Rook take C3 Exchange sacrifice and what
is uh what this Theory suggests now that
black the E6 well the most popular is
a7a6 right and Boeing for this being
that Knight D5 is not yet a threat
because the A2 Pawn is hanging yeah you
can't play Knight D5 because Queen A2
right
and then
of three six yeah not like D5 but King
B1 yes you guessed it right King B1 is a
logical myth but then black can play
Queen C5 and after this Queen's trade
there is no Pawn on A7 so Bishop E3
doesn't really bother black that much
exactly return The Rook to see it and
usually those end games are acceptable
for black and once again Rook takes C3
to my eyes is also completely acceptable
here you might consider the exchange
four yeah very nice looking very
flexible structure plus a Pawn Yeah well
as we would say back in the day yeah we
would jump on this exchange sacrifice
right absolutely absolutely turning our
attention to Magnus and Fabi after
Knight A5 and again that's really off
the beaten path uh thank you uh Sergey
rubleski for that one Queen D3 was found
uh it's amazing even even when you get
surprised like they you know Magnus
finds the The crucial move Queen D3
simply defending the pawn on C4 asking
question what's your follow-up well the
follow-up was D5
D5 CT excuse me that went fast uh D5 C
takes D5 Queen takes D5 gift me The Rook
ready to take uh Queen check
shall we trade Queens yes we will but
let's do it on my terms Bishop D7 I was
calculating while Magnus was thinking
Queen takes B4 hello okay with each one
it's interesting to sacrifice and I
guess the line what if we take on A5
there is Bishop H3 right
and even though we can be disruptive how
disruptive can we be can can we be hide
on G8
you mean King here yes yes king of eight
and if another checking Jade
that's cool
that's gonna have some fun
I was inviting you to
that's big ready take the Rook
and if you take the pawn
um
yeah well first of all you're right I've
run out of pieces but second of all is
like my king doesn't have the most
comfortable uh places you have made
ideas or well I do but maybe you'll just
ignore you know just I mean it's
annoying that after a move like Rook G8
you know just avoiding the loss of The
Rook I don't have the genius
follow-up 96. uh it didn't happen what
was your thought sorry to have
interrupted you there Queen B5 check and
you were going to say Bishop D7 takes
the rook and it's but not take on A5
yeah maybe just develop the bishop and
locked Castle long next move looks
dangerous does it for black for black
yes that's what I thought yeah but of
course Magnus doesn't want to play this
because clearly five is prepared for it
true that and it's hard to figure out in
Rapid what to do exactly when you're
down in exchange and there you go so he
traded and Bishop D2 because uh C3 was
in it pardon me that was my bad C3 was
an issue Knight takes C3 and we've
caught up to the players Miro and is
this in the database or we or in novel
territory
well as I've mentioned it's a extremely
rare lines in fact Queen D3 happens to
be a novelty in the game that I that was
previously played white decided to
sacrifice the pawn on C4 by going Bishop
to G2 I see right and then yes it's it's
quite interesting because the line you
were discussing yeah we went to this
position Queen B5 check Bishop D7 and
then what Magnus did in the game appears
to be in Black's favor so this end game
that they have now Bishop D2 Knight
takes C3 computer turns to favor Black
quite quite seriously well in numeric
terms it's minus 0.7 so almost a pawn up
for black right Pawn takes and computer
suggests Bishop A3 but there is a bot to
it uh after the queen D5 now instead of
Baron instead of Queen D5 Queen B4 okay
as you were discussed but was very very
interesting take the queen takes and
then computer insists on this move and
yeah I may say very very easy to find
sequence Bishop H3 Knight to C7 King to
D7 you take on A8 you develop the king
so by Breaking All the Rules right I
mean King on D2 King on D7 and this is
equal this is what computer suggests and
then one of them is like you can take
the Knight you can seemingly play B7 B6
for whatever reason so you can imagine
how hard it is to play such a position
over the board yeah in Rapid chest as
well I like that uh symmetry of the King
on D7 and the King on D2 and I do agree
with the computer wholeheartedly that
after in the game position B2 takes C3
Bishop A3 just stop for a moment you
don't think the position's that bad I
mean materially speaking the positions
even but the problem is this is an
absolutely enormous Square when the
Knight does land on C4 for example we
just play a move or two Bishop castles
castles Knight C4 you can start to see
right away like well
black has a very comfortable position
tickling the bishop the Rooks are going
to be perfectly beautifully
centralized and no targets look at black
structure versus white structure so I
like uh sorry black is preferable so I
think as strange as it is after G3 to
not fiancaro the bishop maybe that's
what Magnus needs to do after Bishop A3
just play E4 and yeah just
give up the idea Pardon Me That was
supposed to be of having a nice Catalan
bishop and just defending the square C4
but an opening
by the way different move Knight C2 he
didn't
he wants to take consider
through it again sure if he could
and these two very experienced
Gladiators have been going head-to-head
for quite a number of years but I'll
tell you what Magnus is better than two
to one they've played 68 rapid games
only only yeah the trilogy on rapid
chest between them but 37 wins that's a
pretty uh overwhelming score and jump
over to Croatia Zagreb as Christian as a
special guest in studio
thanks yaser I'm with Vladimir furka
Patricia the chief of staff for the
Prime Minister here in Croatia zwornimir
first of all welcome to the show tell us
about your first move uh how excited
were you to do that I'm always excited
since we have the branches too for the
fourth time in Croatia it's a really a
very big event and it's it's incredible
to have so many
top uh the word just player Magnus
Carson of course Wishy and then the the
former
world champion of course Gary Kasparov
who is our fellow Citizen and who help
us a lot to bring branches to decoration
we were grateful for that and that's the
reason why also the the government is
supporting it and the Prime Minister
also
I came for I don't know I think the
third time to open uh officially the
grandchild store this year also so it's
uh it's really a very nice for the for
the Young Generation especially to have
such a number of top players to see from
first hand their incredible moves and
it's very important for us also to
develop chess in schools tell us about
that what are the goals the long-term
goals for the Young Generation
actually you you are aware that we are
the only country uh in the world with
the chess board on our flag so it's uh
the grandchester had to be in in Croatia
at least that Croatia had to be among
the countries hosting grantchester and
uh of course I'm kidding but uh
historically the very first creation
chessboard was eight by eight now it's
five by five so we really had a true
chess board on our on our
coat of arms and for us it's very
important to develop a chess especially
in school because
you have so many games so many video
games but none of them can compete with
the with chess when it comes to how long
we play chess for one Millennium and uh
one 15th centuries and
I'm sure that the chess will be played
for many many centuries to come and and
from that perspective it will be told
you know all the video games so it's uh
it's uh something which is
um uh very
let's say a part of of the general
culture in Croatia and it's it develops
also many skills which very useful for
what would you say those main attributes
that just developed I I will say fair
play I will say also the the ability to
of self-control control emotion because
you see a good move but you don't want
it to be seen by your opponent you don't
have to you you have to you know show no
emotion but also you have to uh you
you
have to decide not the between two
incredible good moves but most of the
time among the less worse move so it's
uh it's a school of deciding how to
decide what is you know the the best
trade-off and and also combining
calculating uh logic analysis and also
maybe a very good balance between
strategy as and and tactics because for
instance the goal is maybe 90 strategy
while I would say maybe I'm wrong but
that chess is hard half so it's a very
good in my view a very good game so
whenever I'm going to put you on the
spot right now who is your favorite
player in this event
of course we have our fellow citizen
Evan sharich who was the European
Champions and we are supporting even of
course and
for the other players it's it's really
difficult to to choose a among among
among them because they have a very
different style of playing and there is
a also a very big difference in
generation we have a vision and who is a
veteran and it's really amazing yeah
yeah and we have a Young Generation like
wukesh like firoza and and some others
and so it's I think it will be
interesting interesting and and of
course Magnus Carson who is always a
very uh
combination he
he does and Fabiano here also we just uh
yeah yeah Fabiano is also incredible and
so
we hope that even charity will do his
best so when we were listening to you
and seeing your knowledge of Chess I
think Croatian chess is definitely on
good hands thank you very much for thank
you very much for inviting
thank you Christian it's always nice
when the political people or politicians
come and say chess helps the nation grow
that's just fabulous oh exciting stuff
is happening in the Fabi game uh Magnus
has sacrificed a pawn in the game
between
nepo and farugia a game that if you said
you know hey this could could also
impact first place I wouldn't disagree
the positions super double edged after
this movement H3 check that was a little
bit of a shock King F1 Bishop F5 and we
you and I have been discussing G takes
H3 and you were saying that you kind of
like Black's position and I was saying I
kind of like White's position uh you
were shocked when I told you yeah like
tell me why you like Black's business as
long as we keep the Queens on the board
I like black because the king white skin
yes but of course if Quince come off
only why it will be playing for a win
but from my point of view I've got two
nights two minor pieces versus a rook
and you don't even have a pawn yet for
it if I play Rook F1 and I you know uh
how do you say clear uh clarify my
issues on the king side I'll be material
ahead yes but I don't think you can
clarify your issues okay why not okay so
the double the pawns are really bad
right agreed maybe people I can improve
on the king side G6 H5 put more pressure
on F3 G6 Rook F1 okay finally on uh I'm
finally ready to uh jump happily with my
knight if I can
Knights love protected squares if I can
play H4 and Knight G5 I'm gonna warm up
to the task uh Miro uh jump in on this
discussion we're having two minor pieces
versus The Rook and a weak and white
king
what say you uh well I you know have no
says inside since I've looked at
computer evaluation uh well few
inaccuracies by the players Knight H3
was indeed a very clever move but
according to the machine he had to
follow the follow it up with an exchange
sacrifice okay so Rook takes F3 well
once again according to machine was
better than some Knight G5 with a check
on H3 and it's relatively balanced it
gives an annihilation of about zero and
by the way White's best bet is not to
save The Rook on e4 but to go something
like King E2 interesting now what
happened in the game after Bishop F5
rookie 3 is the best move and I think
that's Black's problem so black wants
some complication but as long as y just
keeps it solid it's a rookie 3 and then
Rook a to D1 I don't know if yeah it is
it is already played so Knight F4 now a
rook to D1 and yeah White's better
or slightly better and then to
clarify on your discussion
Nazi has an upper hand in this one she
felt the initiative better than you poor
and me so after yeah your line is
perfectly sound up to a point right Rook
E8 Queen G4 and then it's a very very
computer-ish thing once again black has
to play Rook E6 and then this is where
black white finds it awkward because
Queen still there is still a pin on the
f file and it seems doesn't matter what
you do the next move is Queen to F7 I
have missed this for something like yeah
really to G1 Queen to F7 and black once
again doesn't win the material
immediately but it it's extremely
awkward for white Rook F6 is always a
threat yeah so in this case black would
would be better
wow so simply rookie three Rook D1 D1
yeah
D6 I like it yeah
thank you marrow and uh turning our
attention once again to the Marquee
matchup uh between Magnus and Fabi uh
something about magnus's clock there I
think it's down to nine minutes uh
meanwhile Fabi has 21 minutes he's very
well prepared for this game and his
position also looks very good
when we left it there was the move
Knight C2 uh attacking the bishop
obviously the bishop does not want to
retreat the bishop Retreats with simply
Play Bishop takes E3 and where in the
driver's seat but there is this move
Knight A2 which was played by Fabi takes
takes now we've got a knight C2 check
sighting so we can either take the
Knight on A5 which was the choice in the
game or we can take the Knight on B4 he
took on A5 and after check Knight D4 F2
F3 not the very first move that comes to
mind but F2 F3 and Bishop E6 on the
board as Fabby is oops that was supposed
to be simply Knight C6 fabby's preparing
uh castles long Knight C6 and
his last move Bishop E6 means there's no
rookie fight with a check and Bishop is
coming to B3 what can I say it's an
extra Pawn time on the clock uh
everything's going in fabby's white has
any conversation right now two Bishops
just the two Bishops right but it's not
like your two Bishops is a conversation
when they're good Bishops okay
so he did play in the game Bishop C3
uh tickling the Knight reminding there's
Knight G7 and instead of playing a move
like Knight C6 which I think most
players would have played I'm seeing B6
on the board very nice in between move
you like it broke out yes yeah because
it's like where does my Rook go okay uh
thinking picking where you want I can
attack you with another Tempo Knight P3
so yeah that that's one I really don't
like whether whether you include castles
or Knight B3 immediately I'm not a I'm
not happy with so my Rook is actually
messed up so I can we can see on the
camera magnus's body language he's not
happy at all not happy he's in a lot of
trouble already okay but imagine Rook G5
so I wanted you know that was played in
the game and Fabi Castle long
okay and Magnus just played King E1 okay
so this is what I was trying to say is
if we get into a position where
I'm not losing a rope by the way it's
like my Rook really doesn't have that
many squares and once you see a move
like G6 and F6 you start to say well
where does my Rook go if I don't lose uh
my Rook I'm hoping that I will have
compensation with the two Bishops but I
don't I don't feel it I feel a real
disharmony lose the Rook why we'll have
to take on D4 at some point so Rook has
B5 right and after that we have same
color Bishops with an extra Pawn for
black which is great and it's going to
be three versus one on the queen side so
that's a huge Advantage for blood so if
I'm in black shoes and I just play the
move G6 here uh King F2 and if I play
for argument's sake F6 and this is what
you were saying at some point you're
going to have to take the Knight on D4
in order to give your but you know
like wait a minute why are we happy that
about rookie buy it but this one looks
terrible but Miro you you have our
tournament leader uh to contend with
uh right I mean first of all let me
confirm on your evaluation of magnus's
game it does look terrible for white
right well perhaps something was missed
and enough hobby seems to be clearly
winning and speaking of vicious game
remember we were talking about Black's
difficulties of developing the king side
and we've forgotten about one very
typical idea that sarish played in the
game you push the H Pawn and you Disturb
This Queen on G3 and it turned out to
work perfectly well so white girls F3 E7
E5 now Knight is pushed back then after
H4 the queen has to go back you don't
want to go to G5 because Rook H5 the
queen would be trapped right H3
so once again now we already know that
the engine the neural net they really
like pushing those bones and this is
something I believe we've learned from
them so the pawn on H3 is actually nice
Bishop E7 Rook F to D1 and then uh well
I think it's also kind of manure was
noting that
um you can't really Castle because you
drop the h-pawn so it's an artificial
Castle you go to f80 to go G6 and King
G7 that's what he has done on the next
few moves King to G7 Rook D2 and the
last move played was Knight to f8 to E6
well eyeballing those weakened dark
squares well computer games are around
equal and I think in a practical game uh
White has more challenges to overcome so
well very nicely done by sarich so far
excellent thank you Mira I'm very nicely
done by uh Fabi uh so far because what
we've just seen looks like a full
disaster uh for the number one seed in
the tournament after King F2 F6
realizing this nothing uh going on with
Bishop D4 Rook D4 Magnus sacrifice it in
exchange or was forced to give up the
exchange however you want to look at it
Bishop takes G4 F takes G4 and this is
just an overwhelming material advantage
I would say for Fabi at this point and
it's not like our two Bishops are
roaring either you know yeah I wouldn't
be surprised if Magnus
very very soon it looks terrible and he
just like and look at his body uh how
often does Magnus collapse in 20 moves
with white pieces this is incredibly
rare I certainly it it's been ages
operation move Knight A5 I really threw
him off no question about it another
game uh a farooch's game I really like
what uh nepo has done uh Anastasia as at
the opening of this show you know he
explained to nepo at The Breakfast Table
I explained to her how do I win one game
in a row well yeah one game in a row is
doable uh King G1 Knight G6 and this
backward Pawn on D6 is very very tender
how to attack it well I really like this
move Knight on F3 to D2 first of all the
half open f file you're kind of getting
away from Bishop G4 any ideas
but what you really are doing is you're
going to E4 so that you could put
pressure on D6 and this move Knight D2
just you know it's like a star-studded
move ding ding ding ding ding ding ding
you just feel like it hits everything
and in their matchups their head-to-head
matchups
wow that's that's a lot of wins between
Advantage nine wins for ferocious seven
for Ian and nine draws it's a lot of
play and a lot of decisive games Knight
to D2 these players do not like draws
between themselves and I like what uh
nepo has done yeah thus far I think one
game we haven't looked at yet is Duda
yes against lupulasco it's board four
yeah
why didn't get much out of the opening
this is one of those yeah early H4 H7 H6
lines I used to play play this with
white but I must say I never had an
occasion where my opponent got his Queen
on H5 like that that's sort of like uh
crimps
and uh let's just quickly okay
interesting uh but I think a handshake
may be coming very very shortly between
Magnus and Fabi
very pleased with his preparation today
yeah you're a double rations for the uh
seconds
uh in this game Miro I mean uh we were
just between ourselves saying when did
pardon me when did Magnus have a
collapse with the white pieces uh this
egregious and it's been a while
it's been a while it's really really
hard to recall anything like it from the
past years
right so well he will hardly survive
till move 30 and I believe he could have
resigned by move 20. so something really
really bad happened I believe I might
have an idea because once again the
position was unfamiliar to him and I
think from afar he must have missed
something along the lines of this Knight
C2 move because at least according to
machine black is already better but if
black plays something quote-unquote
normal Knight C6 then interestingly
white might have some compensation Rook
to G5 if G6 some Bishop to C3 you push
the Rook away you start moving your H
Pawn forwards in this case it's a little
bit easier on white but after check on
C2 and Knight D4 white is never on time
it's just that simple yeah it's it's
just just bad yeah and the current
position there was a little trick that a
trap that Magnus had said he played the
move King F3 seemingly blundering his
Ewan no no no no no no there is a
discovered check Bishop A6 what's funny
is that even if Fabi fell for it it
would still be good he just he actually
because there's B5 at the end precisely
maybe he should have fallen into uh the
nasty trap you do lose an exchange but
once you see the move B5 you go whoa
whoa whoa whoa because the bishop is
trapped in King B6 in any case uh you
can all uh
it just goes to show how really
excellent the position is for uh Fabi
here as Rook B1 I mean
join this winning position against
Magnus yeah you don't get these uh
opportunities to enjoy this kind of
position but Rook B1 I think would
produce a handshake again you look at
magnus's body posture on the camera
there he's probably trying to figure out
where he went wrong exactly
that happens to me you know when I'm
sitting there I'm in a lost position I
reflect on why I woke up
what did I do you know where was my
blunder I sometimes you see the player
sometimes looking at the score sheet I
think they're going through that whole
mental uh rejiggering themselves and
Rook B1 and Magnus said well okay I can
always resign Rook B1 check this out
um
and Bishop takes H7
there is an H Pawn what did he do pardon
me
after Bishop takes H7
did Bobby have yeah we have some
an error on leeches yes exactly it looks
like he plundered a rook but he did not
he did not he played
okay there we go we have a handshake and
we do have a handshake wow uh I thought
that this was a very very big game
coming into the round today it was but
the way
Fabi won right out of the opening uh was
really something we don't see going to
be interesting to see if Magnus will
recover today after this game and
turning our attention over to you marrow
as you have Duda who at one time used to
lead the tournament yeah how nobody
cares right except for me
let me inform yes I'm very happy with my
pick when we are talking about the
players who are
you know in fight for winning the event
but we'll talk about a little bit later
uh duda's game against lupulasco if you
scroll a little bit back you absolutely
right this queen H5 according to what I
have is a novelty it's a very unusual
move right
you would very often have this position
with white Pawn being on H2 and black
porn being on H7 isn't it right so this
inclusion on move seven of move A2 h2h4
insisting on H5 and then black reacts
with h7h6 changes the position quite a
bit because without those pawns black
has an idea of playing Bishop H3 right
response being on h2h7 so now it looks a
little bit strange even though even
though computer turns to like
and then just a couple of moves
a couple of moves away from the current
position when white has played B2 before
seemingly in a very clever way using the
double pin so you can't take with the c
Pawn because Rook C6 right you can't
take with the Knight because Queen D7
but in fact b2b4 was a mistake because
black could have come up with a very
nasty pin Queen G4 have missed by both
players I believe so now it's a pain
along the fourth Rank and at the same
time the bishop is protected and this
would give like a substantial Advantage
this move and instead of the Knight E5
Queen B3 Bishop E6 Queen A3 now it's
white who is better uh black really has
to take on B4 Queen B4 and now the queen
on H5 is awkward and
uh it's a it's a very typical English
opening right I mean white controls the
C file white has some pressure on the
queen side so yeah now it seems to be in
do this favor
that position mirror if you don't mind
where you played the move Queen G4 I can
really imagine that that mentally you
don't look at that move because when you
see Queen G4 Rook C4 intuitively you
just stop you go why did I play Queen G4
and invite Rook until you see the move
Knight D4 or even Knight b4s or even
that engine tells us right I mean it's
very important that the queen protects
the Bishops that's the point yeah uh but
once you see uh Rook C4 you mentally
switch off you don't see the next move
but uh thank you for that Mira let's
jump over to Zagreb as Christian is
caught up with Fabiano
Fabio Victory against Magnus it's always
sweet but a victory with the black
pieces in 20 minutes that's even better
tell us about the opening phase you
surprised everybody with this move
Knight to A5 what's the story of this
well I prepared this in 2018 for the
match against Magnus I mean we were just
checking like random English lines and I
kind of forgot about this D4 line
basically for a few years and then
recently Magna started to play for
example he played it in Poland against
watashek he beat him he played it online
a bit I think he's he's having very good
results with this line
um I didn't check it today but I checked
it like a few weeks ago and
it's very straightforward this this
whole Knight A5 D5 line I mean it kind
of gets a bit crazy but
um but it's very forcing like he has to
take on B4
if he wants to try for an advantage or
even at each point after Bishop D7 I
mean he has to take on B4
page three oh sorry queen queen H1 Queen
A5 Bishop H3
yeah and now uh this was a draw somehow
I know it's not queen of it's not cb5
isn't it
or not DB5 actually yeah I don't
remember the details of this at all my
DB5 it's some sort of drawing yeah
this this I kind of remember
and okay this was uh
some phrases obviously I'm not
remembering anything but uh it's somehow
a draw but the thing is whatever you're
remembering gives black the advantage so
it's probably a good thing yeah it's
it's very safe for black that's the
thing white has to kind of navigate the
way to equality and I didn't remember
the details but
um I was quite happy when Magnus started
to think because of course white can't
go for this if you don't if you don't
know it but what he went for is very
unpleasant endgame I mean I was
surprised by Knight C2 but I thought
okay bc3 Bishop C5 I thought he would
maybe try Knight B3 Bishop B6 take take
and C4 like I thought okay he
he tries to exchange everything put the
King on C3 and obviously white is
groveling quite a lot here but
drawing chances are anyway High
and that he gave upon and I thought that
it's like very bad like I didn't see how
he's
after 95 I didn't see any move to
survive yeah it's very important that
like Bishop well I don't know very
important but I was going to Castle
okay he can he can maybe play this but
uh I actually didn't see kingy two here
as I see the computer says white can
still fight on but I thought okay
exchange up yeah you're definitely a
driver's seat yeah or if he goes for
something like this is obviously quite
pathetic because I'm just a pawn and
even I have a better position so it's
not just up a pawn but also I'm better
and then in the game his Rook got
trapped I mean he he had to
he had to play rookie five okay he
fights on but he just bonded his work as
well probably a great start to uh day
two we'll let you go get some rest get
ready for the next game and we'll see
you in a few minutes thanks
all right thank you Christian then
congratulations to Fabby uh seriously
yeah it's all going very well uh jumping
uh to a game that's really surprising
nepo is trying to put together a win
and for foreign yes
um
well what to say uh we left it uh after
Knight D2 and since the move Knight D
was Knight D2 was played everything has
gone swimmingly for nepo trades on e4
Queen H4 G3 Queen H5 gift me the pawn
and maybe it was this move uh
that uh through farusha off he must have
missed Knight E8 and the impact of that
move uh nepo is an exchange and a pawn
to the good and uh well uh he's he's
very uh cruising uh yesterday was
terrible just a bad day well actually it
could have been worse and it could have
been worse yes yes I think in both of
the games against go cash and Carlson he
was worse much worse and he saved those
games right so maybe he's just getting
informed now after this yesterday was
warm-up well there's nothing like a
victory to to to change your mindset I
want to put it like that and uh at this
moment he's really on his way uh
exchanging upon to the good and this
move Queen C2 really really does put the
kibosh on the counter play for black
because now this pin is just
yeah exactly it's just it's just awful
and things are really cruising in nepa's
favor let's uh pick up our tournament
leader because uh that game uh unlike so
many others as a board full of pieces uh
maybe one pair of Pawns have been
exchanged that's fine right when we when
we left it uh Miro had said uh push the
pawn to H three get rid of the Queen's
pressure on the G7 square and to my way
of thinking I'm really happy with the
black pieces that this I mean I see a
lot of very nicely coordinated black
pieces I'm seeing Rook take C3 as a
usual type of sacrifice I'm I'm seeing
D5 ideas for black and it's sort of like
white is going to be reacting
and let's just catch up quickly with the
players so Knight f8 and 97 there's a
handshake yeah Nepal won his game
for farrugia where he had a bad start
but uh
the bad start is continuing by the way
uh continuing with vishi after Knight A2
A5
and G5
okay just trying to
this is such a complicated strategical
position and they have five minutes on
the clock oh my goodness uh jump in Miro
I
every all the the is a board full of
pieces and a lot of the pieces look
completely discombobulated what's going
on Knight H5 and I would I didn't want
to suggest this because I thought it
hung the pawn on H3 and right you are
yes and Knight H5 is a mistake after
which Bishop takes H3 leads to White's
Advantage right rights and Knight get G5
Knight to H5 and then he can just take
according to machine yeah what did
sarich Miss I have an idea on what has
happened they both I think missed quite
a bit
and I will have to return wait a second
I'll have to return to this position
perhaps so when it's all started
after Rook D2 Knight f8 Where She Went
a3a phone and usually he would criticize
this move right like you've played A3
and then you play A4 with a Tempo loss
you know in a very Tempo based position
but I believe that after Knight A2
he missed Queen A5 because if Black Goes
A5 there is Bishop B6 right then I start
picking up your pawns yeah after Queen
A5 it turns out that if Bishop B6 played
the pawn is hanging right then after B3
and then this is where Char H well
misplayed it a little bit because he had
to deal with Bishop B6 thread strapping
the queen that's obvious and it was
better done by Knight F6 to D7 avoiding
G5 altogether right or alternatively he
could have stepped in in this bishop B6
just played D5 that is usually how
computer deals with your threats right I
have a thread computer says I don't care
because if Bishop B6 takes takes and
then immediately winning the queen back
and just pay attention how uncoordinated
white pieces are right and this is this
is much better for black while in the
game currently I don't think there was
night age ah there wasn't Knight H5
pardon me there was there was some
glitch right so 98 was flying ah okay
because Knight H5 Bishop H3 is perfect
it was it was lights out right but even
then after Queen d8 Knight takes B4 A5
computer heavily favors white so now
Knight to D5 and the Knight that was in
the other line was you know really
really sad on A2 now it's a now it's a
mighty joseon D5 uh continue the
position if you don't mind mirror
because there's Bishop takes G5 uh after
Knight D5 yeah right and if you would be
playing against me I'd be scared with
what but you know
white is much better that's it wow I
don't know
confidently Play Bishop B5 looks like a
very good move right basically it says
the king is not in danger and in some
cases as I can imagine even like King H1
Rook to G1 and maybe White's gonna use
the G file so that's you know that's
interesting but once again this game
unlike the rest of our round has only
reached move 26 players being low on
time four four and a half minutes each
so everything can happen all right and
just uh turning our attention to do that
again Duda yesterday he started with two
wins could have easily been three in a
row at this exact moment he is up
material against Constantine and uh
should be cruising to Victory position
earlier but he outplayed Constantine in
the middle game and right looks like his
upper pawn and and just to remind
everybody uh two wins a nice start lost
to Richie from a very good position he
blundered a piece he got trapped yeah 95
yeah and uh again uh he he looks to be
winning at this moment so he could be at
six points depending on the outcome of
the game of Vichy uh who's going to be
first Rook A1
uh going after the A7 Pawn exactly
uh
and the problem is it's not that easy to
defend the a pawn if you play play A5 B6
is hanging so Bishop takes G7 and Rook
takes B6 uh you're welcome to trade uh
if you D2 is protected but he
even so uh Rook takes G7 and Rook takes
A7 is the threat I'm assuming uh we
would play Rook here
maybe Pawn E5 I know
it is it is a little awkward to me right
uh
E6 it's interesting right kind of a
funny way how did you how did you manage
to do that well Cafe is the only move
and we can pick up more pawns through K7
and that's that's all she she wrote we
actually have that on the board they
just made those moves
their players caught up with this huh
yeah all the way up into E5
but this is a very awkward move it's
a remarkable if you have to play E6 and
allow Bishop takes and Rook takes that's
not a lot I just play 86. he did okay so
that's I think we're a little bit
delayed on the live board okay yeah I
see that on the light board there but uh
it's it's it's strange to see that
imbalance of four connected past spawns
versus
yeah uh very unusual material imbalance
but uh Miro over to you because uh there
are other games going including the game
of Richie and gukash uh yeah that that's
what I was uh looking at and I've
mentioned that Anand and sarish keeping
the tension but these guys as well
so it's it's not you know not the late
end game right the position according to
machine is still equal and if you recall
it was this funny line with Bishop D2
and in fact I'm happy that once I've
guessed how the game's gonna go so A6
King B1 Queen C5 indeed the same game
happened right F2 F3 h7h5 once again
it's a very typical way to restrict uh
whites at once on the king side
and here we are well
let's jump over to the current position
on the board right so well computer says
it's equal and I suspect it's because
it's hard for black interesting you
usually Rook on the C file is very
useful but now black would like this
Rook to join on the file because I would
suspect if you wouldn't tell me what the
evaluation is I would suspect black is
better with two Bishops you know with
some potential weaknesses of white
spawns but perhaps The Rook got stuck on
the C5 on C6 right so computer says you
can play A4 perhaps grabbing some space
here or start with Bishop G5
relatively balanced and of course a lot
of threshold on both plays
yeah I like how the engine says triple
zeros but I think anything can happen in
this game for sure
I think for a win because he has the two
Bishops
easier to play for black easier
um going back to our game of Duda for a
moment because even though we are two
pawns up it did occur to me that well
after this move Rook E6 Rook takes
excuse me and I can't believe he played
King F3
versus one yeah yeah King uh I was about
to say that okay we're gonna play B5
King E4 we're gonna play B4 we're gonna
try to get this Rook behind the the B
Pawn and it's you
there were two pawns up it's not
it's still tricking yeah it's not
completely cut and dry uh maybe we
should play King to D3 and get ready to
defense yeah get ready to blockade uh
the pawn in case of the move Rook B7 and
of course we want to meet Rook takes
with Rook takes A7
so maybe this move King D3 after B4 uh
will bring due to success I can play f42
because if you go B3 then I'm still in
time I can play
if B2 just Rook B1 and King C2 would win
the pawn
B3 and then something like King C3 well
you want to play King B2 exactly perfect
yeah no that's that's the dream position
for white and that's exactly what Duda
wants uh good question under one minute
so and it can still go wrong with of the
three remaining games again I kind of
feel like there could be a lot of
decisive games in this particular round
uh Vichy did play after Bishop takes G5
he did play the move Bishop B5 Bishop C6
King H1 Bishop takes Knight takes Bishop
takes Pawn takes Queen B6 C4 Knight C5
and again even though the computer might
say you know big Advantage white uh with
the time with with uh all the pieces on
the board I see I still see this as a
three result game I don't think Vichy is
like super confident that you know oh
I'm a I have a plus two advantage or
something like that yes because there's
still a lot of pieces on the board so
exactly but he definitely
and Richie's playing on increment what
is the time situation
um 30 22 seconds versus three and a half
minutes for goo cash but I hear what
you're saying the two Bishops uh it's
it's easier it's easier to blunder for
white
there's the blunder potential Miro you
have to uh you have to constantly worry
about the blunder potential right there
is always easy
we do have a result by the way Duda has
won putting the pressure keeping the
pressure I would say
before King D3 as expected Rook B7 King
C2 and Rook A6 and Constantine had seen
enough he basically says okay my pawns
are stopped you know the Rook the king
and
I'm not stopping for connected past
pawns as soon as you play F4 it start
rolling and Duda three out of four or
three victories very very good and three
for three in terms of game results
proved his position I believe because
the a file opened up for his Rooks so he
traded off his B3 Pawn for the A4 pawn
and I think he wants to play A4 which
probably only benefits white right
so Rook A2 on the board I'm assuming we
have to go backwards because if Rook C4
Queen B3 wins the piece I think that
that looks like a pretty good one
the old double attack it gets them every
time
uh so Rook A2 on the board and expecting
what you said Knight C5 and you've got
the open a file Rook to A1 and Rook to
A7 on on vishi's agenda and Sarah just
down to 25 seconds and here we go Knight
C5 two and a half minutes
yeah this is looking very very good for
white where is black queen going to go
it's one of those things too it's like
it
white has all of the positional trumps
and you start to see moves like Knight
F5 check and Rook A7 and it sort of
feels like you're not going to be able
to deal with everything and uh six
seconds for everyone six seconds Knight
C7 made with six seconds on the clock
oh fish is going for night I had a five
check looks like uh looks like a real
goodie nice because there's
you
boy did you get wake up on the right
side of the bed today look at that
really nice that was
instantly found
and you know
these kinds of moves there's
are as easy as a baby smile it's natural
as a baby's uh four well hold on what am
I saying so it's three but no so he's
got seven out of eight eight wow
incredible results nice Knight F5 check
and uh
well three for three and
no well wait a minute what am I saying
it's four for four in terms of decisive
games and maybe we'll see a fifth
decisive game as well let's jump to go
cash versus Richie report we just have
B5
on the board Knight takes A6 and D5 the
game just blewed up but for whom with
Richie 12 seconds on the clock wait a
minute oh oh oh there is Bishop F5 I was
a what am I missing I I'm thinking
rookie one wins a piece there is Bishop
F5 check he can also include take some
taken C4 right with a check yeah
check
and what a crazy position with only
seconds which you open up the position
from his Bishops which is great but he
has no time and his King is still in the
center and by the way isn't Rook takes
D5 I mean
is kicking here and kicking well Miro
rookie five is the only move to keep the
position balanced for white otherwise
white is in trouble yes I'm amazed with
these guys how they keep finding the
best moves even though being on second
exactly black needs Bishop G3 and so on
and so on it's a very tactical position
and they are still coming up with
resources four seconds four seconds
three two he played Bishop C3 not Bishop
G3 Rook D1 very quickly okay good cash
is actually saying hey wait a minute
maybe it's opportunity is knocking for
me I've got Rook d a check in my pocket
as a way of uh
forcing trades I don't know whose King
is worse exactly night night is ready to
jump
just Knight C5 Knight C5
kukash has much oh the shaking of the
board I don't know if that's the that's
the legs of the players
nervous
uh I think that's Richard's knee yeah
he's nervous
as uh
the camera's getting a little rock
Knight C5 one more time but not that
much 45 seconds uh Mira what did the
engines assess this because I'm saying
it's a three result game uh right you
are and moreover now that I'm looking
through last 15 moves it seems that it
was always balanced there was one tidy
moment especially when you switched on
and rookie one and black could have
gotten an advantage and since then they
keep finding good moves
yeah and he finds it so you're saying
it's triple zeros uh 12.1 in somebody's
favor so so basically yes Brooke takes
A2 on the board
now Rook takes f
4 F pardon me Rook takes F5 I am
allowing Rook F2 oh I like 97. oh yeah
that's uh that's a visual Square as that
that's going to be a triple attack
Bishop B4 just to
it should be four C5 C5 yeah yeah two
wait to see five
I would blunder so easily here either
side yeah probably is close to a draw
because once again computer gives a
check on F2 and well maybe we can drop
it is the compute and then the other
Rook to E2
keeps playing the best moves it's
extraordinary it truly is
uh
the crazy part is the players have come
to expect it of themselves right right I
mean they they criticize themselves when
in an interview why didn't I play Bishop
E1
wait a minute Rook takes E1 rotation
I don't get mated right is that a draw
yeah I think incredible because on King
F3 I have Bishop G4 check exactly one is
it would be a blunder so I have to play
King H2 I think it still looks like a
losing move doesn't it but he's done it
and by the way how much time does
gookash have uh 36 seconds oh my
goodness five seconds right now well
Bishop E4 is going to be met by Knight
D6 but we thought C5 it was the answer
to Bishop B4
didn't we maybe I have some Bishop no I
don't have Bishop B4
uh exactly I always have Knight D6 check
after C5 you can take twice on G2 maybe
that's yeah oh my what a nice what a
nice trick that is by the way out of
four oh
instantly played Rook B5 Rook F3
threatening mate in one
that's a visual so white Rook has to
move D1
where D1 is the only Square according to
machine and don't ask me why you Google
who's the machine there wow Richie or
Google Richard repeat with Rook have two
now
well can we go check and then Rook G3
that's what he's doing
that's what he's done
and he always has the Perpetual in his
pocket you can take the bishop but I've
got at least a perpetual
do I have more Miro yes you do Rook
before loses to Rook G takes G2
F2 and then Rook A2 for whatever reason
but like he's winning he's reaching for
it he's done it he's taken the bishop
okay two seconds okay let's find out and
we'll find out if
this combination is working for black
he always has a draw of course always
but where's the win I don't say it well
it's something with Bishop H3 right Rook
e check to F2 King E1
okay Bishop H3 is a draw because of Ruby
three according to machine yeah Rook B3
is the resource that keeps white ah
because I wanted to play Rook check and
then King G1 then the other Rook but
you're right Rook B3 and he's found it
yeah and in order to win he had to give
a check on F2 first first move the Rook
from F2 to A2 so it won't be hanging
gotcha
now it's only a draw yeah wow
well we're just seconds on the clock to
to
see that nuance
would have been impressive to say the
least
I mean I'm good
all the time I still don't sit
well the idea was that the Rook on E2
wouldn't be hanging so you would have
yeah cage too right that's such a subtle
thing nice nice and there it is uh for
pet coming up with 10 seconds on the
clock Richie
wow
two seconds just don't flag
but I I'm also impressed by gukash uh he
kept this cool throughout and uh he's
saying I'm gonna claim uh the draw with
just uh back and forth repetition and
the players the only draw of the round
terrible right
great stuff tell the audience where he
missed it just the victory at the end
because it's a very nice uh and and this
pattern you really should hardwire into
your brain go ahead yes so here it turns
out the only move was to force
elimination of one of the Bishops the
Gill Knight D6 and then you have a
choice of Gumtree in the night or moving
the king elk after your bishop and that
would somehow hold and in our game of
the route before he's done it first move
well obvious check King F1 and then
as we've already discussed it was a
check and
Rook to A2 so that you are threatening
Checkmate in one
and if white says okay I go King F1 now
Bishop H3 works
and the point being of course that in as
in the game Rook B3 there is there is
Rook G3 Checkmate in two in fact from G3
King goes through G1
and the whole point is there's not a
rook on E2 look on E2 is not hanging so
as it was in the game right so after
Rook B3 he would have liked to get Rook
H2 or Rook G3 but then the other Rook
would be hanging exactly and apart from
this little moment yes I think this must
be the highest quality game so far yeah
that's enough thank you very that's a
really a beautiful one that Rook A2
first uh as we get prepared for vote uh
for break I was gonna say after this
round let's check in with our friends at
Q Boutique at the World Chess Hall of
Fame a jacket this is the newest edition
of the World Chess Hall of Fame jacket
and it is not to be missed these jackets
are 95 polyester and 5 Spandex and
feature an outstanding durable hot
pressed logo at the World Chess Hall of
Fame on the front it's available in
men's and women's Styles at cute
Boutique St
louis.com as we get paid prepared for
breakfast we're going to show our
standings Nasi a very eventful round
four and after four rounds Anand remains
his lead uh with seven points right uh
still closely following yeah Christoph
Duda just one point behind and now Fabi
and Richard are with plus one yes yes
but a very very big victory by Fabio
Fabi indeed and as we go to break
Anastasia got a chance to catch up uh
with the players uh for some interviews
hope you enjoy we'll see you on the
other side
[Music]
if you played in 2019 and also my
congratulations on your victory in
Dortmund you're just coming from this
event where castling was not possible
and I wonder if you have reached the
conclusion is it good to Castle or not
I think I think it's good to Castle I
wonder how it would uh how long I'd be
able to survive if I couldn't Castle but
my opponent could I think maybe not not
very long against good players it was
definitely a pretty big challenge to try
to adjust to that type of Chess so I
enjoyed it but you know I wouldn't want
to play it every single tournament so
I'm glad to be playing normal chess
again yeah but I think against whom in
this tournament do you think it would
work this kind of strategy without
castling well I Richie is playing right
exactly yeah that's what I thought the
reason I was thinking that was because
in in the candidates last year we played
a game uh where instead of castling I
moved my Rooks to F1 into D1 so it
looked like I was trying to Castle but
unable to figure out the rules where I
actually also move my king and I think
people uh kind of paid attention to that
and they almost called it like no
castling chess especially in the
candidates because it's such a serious
tournament you don't expect to see some
kind of strange things but during the
game you don't even think about it like
you're just making your moves and
sometimes some unusual things happen so
maybe against Richie I think that we
would we would manage quite well to find
a way not to Castle even in normal chess
yeah I think so too because I remembered
that I was kind of checking when will be
this moment here with castle in the
games and normally it was after move 15
then sometimes never happened
no he's a very original player for sure
yeah and whom I also looking forward to
playing this event
um it's a different field a little bit
um
yeah I think gukesh is always very
interesting as a young player alireza of
course Magnus
um I think against Magnus I haven't
played rapid and Blitz since the world
championship we played one Blitz game
one rapid game there okay we played a
lot of online but uh speaking strictly
about over the board chest since the
world championships and almadi we
haven't played uh any wrapped in Blitz
and we also avoided Armageddon in in
Norway so that'll be interesting uh and
you know I like to see the the young
guys because they're always changing in
terms of how they how they approached us
how they play and so it'll be
interesting to see how they perform and
um but I have to say all the players are
interesting you know it's it's not like
you have any
um any guys who are not fighting every
game here so so I think we have a good
mix of players yeah for sure and you won
the classical event in Romania and now
we're playing in rabbit and Blitz I was
wondering if you ever won any rabbit and
Blitz event on grantchester I mean do
you recall no I haven't I can say that
pretty pretty confidently uh the best
I've gotten was second place I think in
maybe more than once but I remember uh
one year Nakamura ran away with the
tournaments in St Louis wrapped in Blitz
and Saint Louis I think it was 2021 but
I could could be mistaken but I think
I'm pretty sure it was 2021 and he was
dominating it and I was having a good
tournament but it was only enough for
second
uh one of like my I felt it was kind of
unfair last year I was playing in Poland
and I scored plus 10. and I got fourth
place and I thought this was really not
fair at least like plus 10 you should
get like second place or something but
but everyone was playing really well
there that was that was the issue so
sometimes even if you're playing well
you still have to you have to play
better than your opponent so that's for
sure but does it bother you a little bit
you know the fact that you have never
won any rapid event I I would definitely
like to win I I have to say I in general
the grand just tour I haven't had the
best results for some reason
um over the years I think the best I did
was third place and and grantchester's
tour so I don't know why it is but I
haven't shown the consistency that some
other players have who are very
successful here like let's say Wesley
obviously Magnus Hikaru uh so I'm hoping
to improve this year
that's great and actually
grunches too what do you think
granchester has what kind of impact it
has on the history of Chess and that's
your own career
yeah I think now we're starting to see
the kind of
Resurgence and popularity of these uh
these giant chess tours that start at
the beginning of the year and culminate
and the grand Chester was the first to
do it I think 2015 was the first time uh
and it looks very different in terms of
the tournaments we were playing there
but the format was similar and then at
some point there was a Innovation to
have some sort of final like a final
four which was uh we played a few times
in London the the
um some sort of knockout deal yeah many
matches and that was very interesting
too in fact I would I hope some at some
point to see a return to that because I
I like the idea of like a a final and
like final matches and uh some sort of
big
um you know culmination of the of the
event but I I think the idea of a tour
branches tour was uh was definitely
innovating and it's now we see that it's
a great format a lot of other organizers
are also trying it out yeah that's for
sure and about for you for yourself for
your chest development did it help for
you as a player to participate in all
these events no of course it's been
great to every year to have a series of
events that are super high level high
quality well organized uh I have to say
I don't know about like the development
of my child's because I was already kind
of a decent player when these this
grandchild store started but definitely
every year it's been great to come back
into place yeah thank you so much and
all the best of luck for you in this one
thanks thank you
[Music]
time to fight for titles the best
juniors girls and Senior chess players
converge in the chess capital of America
St Louis Missouri for the U.S junior
girls and Senior championship
beginning July 15th 30 players will
compete across three fields for over a
150 000 prize fund
this tournament features the top Junior
and senior chess players in the nation
including the young up-and-comer Karissa
yip
Young Junior Phenom ABI Manu Mishra and
returning senior Champion Alexander
shabalov
three titles are on the line and you
won't want to miss it catch all the
action on the St Louis chess club
YouTube and twitch channels
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States we
bring the educational benefits of Chess
to thousands of students across the St
Louis area we also promote Chess at the
highest levels hosting all levels of the
U.S championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why Jess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game the World Chess Hall
of Fame has something for everyone to
enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chess sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
the beauty in Forest Park
it's your move the muni premiere of
Chess plays the muni through July 11th
sponsored by St Louis chess club and the
World Chess Hall of Fame for
ticketsmuni.org
foreign
chess club is the Premier chess facility
in the United States and is among the
best in the world thanks to co-founders
Dr Jeannie Karen sinkfield and Rex
sinkfield the St Louis chess club is a
non-profit organization committed to
promoting the game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomed
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the U.S
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sync field cup
Cairns cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over 2
000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
[Music]
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why chess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game landmarked by the
world's largest chess piece sitting
outside our front door the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy including various exhibitions
monthly concerts and much more whether
you are a beginner or a professional
there is something for everyone to learn
here at the World Chess Hall of Fame
enjoy free admission to our rotating
exhibitions in our Galleries and sign up
for chess events family friendly
programming and art classes and don't
forget to stop by our award-winning gift
shop Q Boutique and Shop a wide
selection of Chess related merchandise
for more information on current exhibits
please visit worldchess hof.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the world-class St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
thank you
welcome back everybody to our grand
Chester OH that round four was exciting
and afterwards the standings Nasi right
let's take look viciana still leading
the tournament with seven points out of
eight wow but look at the yandita is
really putting the pressure on him yeah
just one point behind is Young Crystal
of Duda and then with plus one score
Fabiano caruana and Richard Rapport our
number one seed at 50 Magnus Carlson
Jana just got a victory but tell us
about the pairings for round five
exciting parents we have feruza playing
Magnus Carlton two very wounded players
looking at one another yes uh Richard
Rapport playing the Promenade nice the
pulasko playing go cash sarich versus
Duda and Fabiano caruana wow what a
marquee matchup as we have number one
and uh Vision on our tournament leader
against uh Fabi that's just the fitted
Madness in about 20 moves wow as we get
ready for this round five Miro jump in
that was I have to say one of the most
exciting rounds and during our break we
looked at good cash and Richie and what
they did in those last 20 moves was a
remarkable yeah indeed I mean it wasn't
the flashy game perhaps but it was a
very very intense and very high quality
game played by gukesh and Rapport and
I'm looking forward to vicious game
against Fabio rather fabies against was
she Fabi with white pieces you know
after beating Magnus with black and 20
moves well I'd be scared if I would wish
well all of these guys are definitely
monsters but that is going to be a great
game for sure and uh well we got our
predictions
I'm not happy about this but you're but
you're competing that's what it's all
about that
I'm happy with Judah and I think you're
very happy too Miro with Bobby yeah yeah
well actually it changed for the better
right I mean the moment I picked Fabi it
didn't look very well but since then
maybe someone told him yeah but uh
Danish uh also happy with his uh Choice
with Richie if Richie had played that
move Rook A2 who had been happier still
but uh oh wow what a start and and we
had today for this day two you know it's
hard to believe that world number one
Magnus Carlson is in the middle of the
standings
true that and again Vichy you know 53
years young and he just makes it look
effortlessly when he's in his Zone Duda
by the way once again all of his games
have been decisive and he could have
very yeah and he could the game he lost
to Richie yesterday in round three could
very easily have gone his way
and let's take a look at the head to
head between these two Gladiators
they've played a lot of games
and it's really really close yes 15 wins
for Fabi 14 wins for Vichy and 21 draws
in Rapid chest They Know Each Other Well
and it goes to show uh you know the
longevity of I'm always amazed how do
they still surprise each other in
openings when they have 100 if we
combine rapid Blitz and classical
they've had hundreds of games clear and
I think Miro the answer to that question
is The Passion of The Players you just
have to have this desire to come back
again and again and again passion
dedication and hot hot work can be
underestimated yes because yeah well a
lot of people passionate about the game
you know enjoy playing but this work
behind what really makes it different
right we probably know how much fobby
works yeah
let me tell you guys a a bit of trivia
that may come in very handy of every
unique to win a a bar bet
can you name a chess player who has a
planet named after him now I know
but this is my problem with NASA why did
they choose a minor planet they should
have had a major planet
so apparently Alexander
anatolic have also had planets named
after him nice this she and not 45 28 is
what they call it 45-28 Bishop it's a
minor planet between the orbits of Mars
and Jupiter the dwarf planets that's
incredible nice uh I didn't know that
about carpa for Alexander either and
help me out the Russian pronunciation
for Italian
it's not alkyne what Americans would
call alkyne
no as we get ready uh this is a huge
matchup uh Miro uh we saw the
head-to-head very very close prediction
quickly E4
D4 E4 computer has it as the best move
and of course the Karo Khan just as said
Nasi and I were expecting
right no no E5 uh
oh the fantasy variation F2 F3 I always
love to play against the fantasy
variation I thought I felt I was better
and what do you choose here I would take
on e4 and play E5 it's the most
aggressive line the most aggressive but
my my my choice B was F7 F6
oh pardon me G7 G6 sorry why did I say
F7 F6 G7 G6 yeah pardon me that was uh
not right I've played Queen B6 and E6
yep yeah there's many moves and I think
which is choosing now uh but G6 is my
backup line and takes takes E5 and what
is crucial here is after the move Knight
F3 you have to play Bishop E6 in order
to stop Bishop to C4 and yes so many of
my opponents have blundered with Knight
takes on E5 and after Queen check I was
already better with the black pieces uh
so early in the game E4 is happening
hanging but F2 F3 uh E7 E6 I think
that's the most popular move nowadays
right because you're saying to white
great you get the I'll play the French
defense and you get F3 for for free yeah
and after Knight C3 Bishop B4 B Bishop
D2 on the board
is there a pesky could I take this or
you will take with the Knight I can can
I take this yeah take with the names so
on 24 I have C3 important yes C3 exactly
okay so you're sorry to you were about
to suggest 97. yeah on the queen side
we've played B6 often and sometimes
Bishop A6 yeah and just get your king
out of uh Dodge gotcha uh marrow over to
you uh four other very exciting games
going on as well what uh caught your
attention uh while I was actually
checking
this one caught your attention you know
I'm involved
yeah it is uh relatively rare line but
still quite a lot of games here
remarkably black has a variety of
choices and some weird moves like a
caption C3 exists and even a7a5
uh right
a785 a7a5 protecting the bishop perhaps
yeah but the main move of course Nazi
mentioned Knight to e76 but to E7
uh turning to our attention to the game
between Ali Reza and Magnus for a moment
because we have the two knights uh
usually against Bishop C4 the Joko piano
they are playing Bishop C5 but Knight F6
does invite Knight G5 which was not
essayed by Ali Reza d2d3 Bishop C5
transposing into the Joko piano and now
we're seeing this bishop G5 which I find
um
I want to say premature I think that the
move Bishop G5 went black has not
castled you really are provoking G5
and it feels to me like black is the one
who's getting the initiative uh
surprising that Magnus didn't play G5 no
he played oh and sometimes you you prep
G5 with a move like Queen E7 because you
kind of want to see white tuck as king
over on the king side before playing G5
but A7 A5 uh are we worried about B2
before I'm not sure but A5 was his
choice Bishop B6 and we've kind of
caught up with the players here I'm
assuming Knight D2 and if I'm not
playing G5 how am I dealing with this
pin
I I think sooner or later you have to
play J5 I think yeah I think it's going
to be sooner because the longer you
delay it's going to be harder for you to
get that to achieve that move uh jump in
Marrow and tell us is this
uh well Theory uh the the the the moves
A5 and B Bishop B6 are not natural to my
eyes for Magnus uh right yes I'm
actually trying to figure out with some
transpositions we are still perhaps in a
in a familiar territory
uh as you may see yourself it's like a
handful of moves possible in this
position which by the way once again
Bishop G5 is not the most popular just
explains how wildly the theory has
developed in this Joko piano so H6 some
people in fact Play Bishop B3 claiming
that H6 is a you know a bad move Bishop
H4 and then once again we are back to
normal a7a5 is one of the moves even
though A6 happens to be the most popular
one
G5 as you've mentioned yet of course
this idea exists before black Castle
short so A5 castle and Bishop B6
according to what I see has never been
played before you have games of Magnus
Carlson here Hari Krishna well a lot of
strong players played it with black uh
the Top Choice was it of course G5 and
if black was to move this bishop uh they
would prefer to move it on A7 so Bishop
B6 no new games
and white replied with King H1
interestingly so far not playing Knight
to D2 computer still insists on playing
G7 G5 here after Bishop G3 regrettably
you can't yet play H5 sometimes it is an
idea and after Knight G5 to go H4 you
know but it's too much F7 is hanging so
after Bishop G3 it's very typical
maneuver go to E7 go to G6
relocate this Knight maybe go C7 C6 at
some point and black has well decent
chances
very a very sophisticated stuff I'm not
sure I understand Bishop B6 myself I
want to just turn our attention to Ivan
sarich versus adira Duda is in second
place behind Vichy and he's playing a
Berlin solid Choice with the move a7a5
and okay you know what can I say about
the Berlin that hasn't already been said
the extreme flexibility of the Berlin in
these positions you can play H7 H5 you
can play H6 you can play Bishop E7 in
order to bring the Knight to H4 you can
play Bishop to D7 and or E6
even Bishop B4 I think all of the theory
and then you play a move like A5 and you
go I can do everything and Yvonne is
saying well maybe you can and maybe you
can't the fact that you haven't played
H5 encourages me to play the move G4 and
trying to put his
um majority to work right away with the
move Knight G5 prepping F4 yeah so black
needs to move the bishop back now Bishop
D7 it seems right and just F4
very good for white yeah the the and
that's also the the problem yeah yeah
that's always the problem with the
Berlin is visually uh a lot of times it
appears that you just you you're just
doing very well and then you'll end up
getting hit by a move like H5 and the
computer will say well Black's only
slightly better and you go what you know
be better what have I done wrong are we
still in the theory mirror uh well not
any not anymore Knight G5 being the
first the first independent move uh it's
funny yes when you were explaining about
this position right so how many options
black has I've actually
managed to literally count the moves
that are that were played in the
database it's nine different
possibilities for like Believe It or Not
Right A5 being well not the rarest but
not the most popular of course B3 then
Bishop E6 I'm not sure if it's a good
move it was played but yeah so Bishop E6
and as you can see there is only one
game after G4 now interestingly computer
claims that was clever to go Bishop
before something that he would not
expect normally it doesn't work because
white captures captures right right but
here The Rook on A1 will be hanging and
then according to machine uh the whole
point is that you are not blocking the
bishop on f8 so you go Knight E7 or
other option even take on C3 first and
sometimes those positions are played
I've never
never been happy with black getting this
position but it could be playable the
opposite color of the Bishops somehow
ensure uh that black is not think
terribly worse position so 97 Knight G5
Bishop D7 uh F4 was possible
F4 was possible because after age five
it seems F5 works it works yeah F5 works
and h g a g usually you're worried about
Rook H4 right exactly but here Rook F4
somehow and keeps it together and the
Knight back to F3 getting rid of this
Rook so it's very unusual but it
seemingly Works remarkable but yeah Rook
D1 and black replied with Knight to D5
sacrifice I think D1 was intended to
stop Yes you want to play Knight D5
white says but well let's see let's see
and interestingly interestingly once
again if you trust the computer white is
better but not because he's taking a
phone he goes Knight E2 and that's
that's seemingly the best move perhaps
planning to kick the Knight away and
then return
yeah Berlin stuff no at the Berlin uh it
really is uh a challenge it's it's very
very hard and I don't know if you would
agree but the evolution of theory in
Berlin was like before cramly kaspar of
much it would be a rare opening and
there was no strict Theory exactly you
exchanged the queens and then you played
the end game right right and then
kramnik played it on a very high level
and it started to develop and at some
point it looked like it's a very very
narrow path you have to specifically
play this chromic setup with Bishop to
D7 King 2 C8 and with stronger When
stronger computers turned in it turned
out that the previous guess was right
you can literally play anything with
black and be fine you just have to know
your opening wow
I'd like to just turn our attention for
a quick moment to the game between
Richie and Ian
nepo as nepo got his first win in a row
first win in a row that's very important
uh Richie a Headhunter that he is Queen
D2 a yeah
you know somebody who goes for the king
you know I mean very exciting look at
him maneuver in his face we saw that
yesterday exactly and F4 well just a
moment ago against gukesh as he set up
that beautiful checkmating pattern he
was that close to the win F4 Knight C6
F5 let's go
F7 F6 and we've caught up to the players
probably preparing to play G5 and black
things yeah and here's the head-to-head
lifetime between these two players I
wanted to ask what you thought it was
going to be and I was not even close
somehow I was expecting a lot more games
between last five rapid games between
this two and young has two wins and
three draws wow uh yeah I was way off in
my expectation F7 F6 and what you were
saying was that after Knight G4 okay I
want to obviously uh Queen H6 check you
thought G5 to shut things down a little
bit I think so yeah and here number six
is scary yeah exactly here if I go H4 H6
Munch Munch yeah
and I make a pretense
Rook h8 a rook h
one and probably develop my Bishop just
so I could connect right connecting the
Rooks but I do have rook h8 and Rook H1
the H1 is not protected oh
yeah exactly the king should be on G2 I
I probably yeah exactly I probably for
that reason I might I I maybe I should
have started with G3 in King G2 to keep
the Rook the H1 Square protected we'll
keep an eye on this one as we turn our
attention to our leader this one-a-thon
Anon this she did I think he sacrificed
upon sacrifice upon well
this year asked the same question I
asked which was okay in this position is
D4 tender right if I take on e4 and you
take with the Knight stop so we'll just
stop for a second and I'll say to you
how are you loving F3 you know like and
you would say to me yes sir I hate F3
you know because you played F3 with one
purpose and that one purpose is that you
will always want to recapture with the
f-pawn you'll open up the f file you'll
get the center you bring your knight to
F3 so it's really awkward and then she
said okay now that your Pawn is on F3 I
am going to make this break I'm going to
try to prove that you've really messed
things up and
if we play a Berlin we take the pawn on
C7 off the board we're not that unhappy
are we
I think even now with black is
definitely has conversation for the pawn
oh big time yeah I'm I'm wondering if
I'm not a little bit well better yeah I
think that might be an overview for
black to be better exactly the problem
is uh as I play a move like Bishop C7
and I win back the pawn on E5 I'm
worried that you might play a move like
Knight D4 and or Knight G4 and to just
take the bishop and say okay I'll give
you back the pawn on E5 but I'll get uh
a light squared Bishop in return marrow
jump in on this one I like the pawn
sacrifice does the engine agree with
Vichy uh while the engine criticized E5
at first
well saying you didn't really have to do
it right B to D7 play something normal
right pretty much yeah I wanted to drive
your attention guys to a position after
move six of the vision apparent after
Bishop E7 because if you think of it
it's French defense Rubinstein
variations right de4 Knight takes E4 and
then black played Bishop E7 and white
has a Tempo up because black spend one
tempo C7 C6 the move that you don't
really need but it's okay and white has
two most played but one of them is ugly
move F3 and the other one the ugly move
Bishop D2 so in fact it's a position
where you are Tempo but you would prefer
your Pawn to be on F2 right right so E5
is of course a move that you want to
play like from Human perspective right I
mean white is undeveloped is really F3
is awkward but yeah machine says it is
still a pawn
uh well so far so good yeah perhaps he
yeah he according to machine interesting
he had to take with the opponent for
whatever reason it was better
okay and if black wants to trade perhaps
you take with the bishop and then have
an option of protecting this Pawn
so in the current position of the
Castle's long Bishop C7 was played
Bishop D4
H6 H3 and let's look at the machine we
are still slightly famous slightly
favors what
uh so if we just makes oh uh A7 is
really hanging uh yeah but first I
wanted to go castles but right maybe uh
just Bishop A7 and then you want to trap
the bishop of course and there is a
little problem with your idea
I trap my king that's a nice one so uh
that's unfortunate because I wanted to
say that if I could just Castle play
Rook E8 and comfortably win the pawn on
E5 I would be better by the way A7 A6
not exactly the move that fishy wanted
to play but he does want to Castle yeah
he does want to Castle he does want to
play Rook a28 later on there might be a
slight problem with the you know with
the final part of your plan because in
order to win the E5 Pawn not only you
have to put the Rook on the e-file let's
say white does something Bishop B2
castles and just right Bishop C free
yeah right okay you see whenever I start
making human moves they are better and
then rookie eight the point is you still
have to move the point was that say Rook
E8 and still you need to move the bishop
somewhere in order to attack E5 one more
time and it's not easy to do exactly and
computer claims white to be slightly but
better in every imaginable line okay
very interesting and again uh for Vichy
I want to say this is actually a huge
test for him this game right here uh
he's in the lead which is always very
nice of course uh but he's playing Black
against Fabi even if he gets through
this test I mean he'll be looking at
those Blitz Games with uh with with Zeal
but this is going to be a very awkward
uh test for him
and let's just jump to the game between
farrugia and Magnus is again we have two
very wounded players after that round
four and let's see what has happened
well we did cg5 it took us a while after
King H1
um
Magnus had seen enough
Magnus made two moves like A5 Bishop B6
they were not maybe yeah and meanwhile
white improved the position I like
ferocious Knight on C4 very much so yes
so looks like white should be better
absolutely and even though I'm not
coming also
D4 coming now yes even though I'm not
the the biggest fan of Moves Like King
H1 uh it's just that I don't see the
bishop on B6 in the pawn on A5 as being
optimal from Black's point of view and I
do think that D4 is coming and even
though I'm not playing H4 and you know
trying to weaken the pawn on G5 I am
playing D4 trying to force e takes what
should black king do stay in the center
or still Castle short that's the big
question right you always have to ask
yourself in the opening where am I
putting my king
and again just to look at the scoreboard
and to see uh Magnus and Magnus is here
in fifth place is in the ninth place at
the moment hello I mean Ali Reza once
again let's do both of us Rochester
winner exactly the grand Chester
champion and I remember what a two-week
three-week period he had it here in St
Louis last year as he won uh
the rapid and Blitz the hundred thousand
dollar bonus and it was sort of like
he said in an interview that as a young
player he dreamed of coming to St Louis
and competing with the world's best he
didn't dream of coming to say but I was
winning everything and competing with
the world's best but is what he did and
he was only 19 at the time
exactly incredible uh jump in Miro uh
what is the engine's assessment of the
position we like farrugia oh sorry you
have a different game I do have a
different game and sorry for praying
kind of breaking news but just look at
the board it does look like something
from it named so Indian which is only a
start guess what in three moves in three
moves
misplayed it completely so B7 B6 well
Bishop develops to B7 and white is
supposed to play E4 and that's what he
does and looks he takes he takes Bishop
A6 ever heard of pins
uh oh so it was a terrible blunder this
E4 move right and yeah okay Bishop D3 is
the only thing you've got exchange takes
Rook a to C8 even some intermezzos first
I mean it's a very annoying move because
yeah what what do you do one take Stakes
yeah black is completely winning out of
nowhere wow one two bad moves Knight G3
and E4 this will be good Cash's first
one if he wins yeah it will yes it will
be right for Constantine he knew it was
a challenge coming in as a wild card
against this
well I want to say a group of murderers
they are tough uh we saw yesterday he
had winning chances against Fabi he did
he did uh but again uh this move Knight
C4 Magnus is on the back foot as again
I'm I'm ready to play uh Knight takes B6
and I'm very eager I'm extremely eager
to play D4 I'm going to play a bad move
okay just for uh to I I think that that
I I want to show
you know an epic fail you know just uh
bear with me on this one so uh move like
D5 takes Knight takes Pawn takes
Bishop takes Pawn takes Bishop takes
Bishop takes and structure exactly
that's exactly what I wanted to say is
just look at this ugly Pawn structure
double Pawn split Pawns
two sets of double pawns uh split pawns
everywhere uh even the minor pieces it's
just so bad so this is you know what
everything that can go wrong and that's
really based on E5 takes D4 allowing
this bishop takes F4 so this is I think
is what Magnus is really trying to avoid
yes he's very very fearful that D4 will
will provoke this move E5 takes D4 and
if he's forced into that
you know like time out you know you got
a a trainer there throwing in a towel
saying I'm not gonna collapse 20 moves
again right my guy's taking too many
blows what is uh are you gonna do yeah
please here I don't know oh sorry I was
gonna check with Richie and Nepal's game
okay things have developed very
differently than what we expected
snow G5 because Richard it was supposed
to be a Checkmate on the queen side yeah
wow okay he didn't play Knight G4 Knight
G4 provoking G5 he took on G6
9g for now so he won the light Square
Bishop but I feel like Black's doing so
well in the center and on the queen side
he really is but okay so B that a pawn
is actually
yeah true that
what if we exchange the knights and then
play A2 if I'm not losing that pawn it's
there it's it's there yeah
it's on the doorstep it's it's it's not
something that you see that often right
um
and by the way he did uh exchange on E2
and this is the opportunity for A3 A2 he
played Knight A4 which my a very nice
tactic tactical move actually even
better right because you're looking by
the way that's an easy move to miss nice
Snap On Fire after that first win the
first win in a row uh good to get that
uh in your belt under your belt uh Miro
Knight A4 and
um
Yeah Richie's body posture is like oh
dear I miss that and nepo was actually
like boys yeah like hey it's good
this tournament just improved a great
deal tell us about the move Knight A4
and why it's so strong Knight A4 is
strong for uh for a very very reason
that it wins the pawn right you cannot
take ba3 because Knight C3 and he just
replied with Bishop E6 so now black can
and shoot take on B2 should he or should
he play D4 well that's once again I'm
thrusting the machine on this one so
just take on B2 okay and when The Rook
moves
when The Rook moves there is
interestingly C4 this is maybe not an
easy move to find and the point be that
you have a sneaky threat of Queen B6
check right because you were thinking
okay what's C4 I'll take on C4 right
right the bishop and yeah so you take on
D5 then and black captures on D3 and too
many of them past pawns so White's
attack on the king side is no longer
realistic speaking of which F takes G6
happens to be a mistake he had to go
Bishop G4 according to the machine where
it would be dangerous for black to try
to block because H4 and if H6 this
Knight all of a sudden is very quick
getting to H5 and the black's position
is very dangerous in this line and since
he captured on G6 black is well perhaps
out of major trouble and then later on
Jan went to a late Richie and now looks
looks for uh for a win by the way
nepo is looking away from the board
after this move Bishop E6 and he's
coming he did sorry on B2 with the pawn
which actually looks very logical to me
because C3 is still hanging
sure so not sure why Knight B2 was
better because because this looks very
good this allows Bishop takes D5 once
and after Knight C3 Knight takes C3 the
risk Queen B2 and if you take on D1
there is a check on B7 and I take an A8
I see and I mean he may have missed this
black is better still
A8 and then save the Knight by going
Knight B2 and Knight D3 and it might be
that black is winning the resulting end
game right but what computer claims to
be the best line that after Queen B2 you
can also take on D5
simple probably this one is simply
because your opponed up and white has
the weakness on D3 and also the king is
very big there is always some Rook A2
thread like for instance here
you really have to play Rook B1
intending to swap the queens and it
might still be losing this end game so I
still believe Black's chances are very
very good A3 takes B2 would you rather
take on D1 or D5 which end game looks
better for you for me taking on D5 is
simple and really good let's jump back
to Fabi and Vichy again a key marker Key
matchup in this round as these are two
players leading the events probably kept
the extra upon all the all the way till
the end but yeah
those doubled e-pawns aren't those
grade B5
and uh okay we're we're not winning the
pawn back anytime soon but on the other
hand it basically means this night
is Tethered it can't move and we're
playing if you will a bishop ending
yeah because the knights are somehow and
and you don't want to play H4 because
that would allow Bishop to G4
um
and I don't see the problem for black
but uh well maybe it's just one of those
positions of mutually you you neither
side can make progress by the way I've
improved with Kings yeah making moves
and uh by the way for some strange
reason I thought that
you shouldn't take here because if I go
C6 takes B5
are you trying to create a password yeah
I'm trying to create a password but
maybe create a password with C4 at some
point right but that's a a pawn that I
can easily blockade okay maybe B4 here
that's the problem is I think you can
just play B4 and just more or less uh
just
hold uh it uh there Miro it's an extra
Pawn for white I don't know if the
computer likes it that much but I'm
thinking Vichy has an easy game is it
true uh right you are right you are and
yes a B5 cb5 was possible but ab5 as
well she played is just simply a
um nothing for whites interestingly
probably you want to play B4 and then
black seemingly has a little track trick
which he doesn't need but can play C5 if
captured then of course King C6 King
capture C5 if C3 then just just stands
here King B6 King C6 in order to try to
make progress you'll have to take on C5
black recaptures with the King then goes
B5 B4 okay say captures here captures
here goes B4 just liquidates it
liquidates everything and it's easy easy
draw
um
uh we've got five games going on and not
like the round four where you know uh
there's decisive games in abundance
still has a very good position against
Magnus he did take uh when we left it
well Magnus Pursuit matters on the king
side he played H final we can say more
and more people yeah the audience
as the day goes on and exactly things
get more exciting a little bit surprised
by Knight takes B6 again I you know
thumping the table pretty hard for D4
but Knight takes B6 Knight D2 I think uh
farouzia felt it was judicious
to sidestep the move a G5 G4 probably
wants to meet that with H4 King f8
wow
King on G7 and still kept The Rook on h8
I think that's very smart okay so how
are we meeting
very very nicely Knight C4 uh finisher
played D4 D4 which by the way the
combination of those two moves is what I
want I want both D4 and I want Knight C4
I like white
uh it feels like there's a lot of
disharmony in Black's uh situation but
maybe I'm underestimating the attack am
I uh marrow I mean G5 H5 I don't feel
the pressure do you want the
confirmation everything that you just
said okay absolutely right yes I'm
fishing for conflict okay so first
things first you write the D4 was a
stronger move okay however after G4 it's
not everyone's liking that you really
have to sacrifice a piece well
temporarily and white is much better and
black shouldn't take really should
return the piece back by capturing on E5
but yeah it's not that easy to
understand that if black insists on
keeping the material that this is
completely winning Bishop takes Bishop
takes and Knight E5 right it's not
rocket science it is possible to
calculate but one of the reasons why you
might not go for it in a rapid game
because your position is already too
good right already so good yeah right
and then Knight takes B6 it doesn't drop
the advantage okay it's not the most
precise but still white is much better
after King f8 D4 Knight E7 let me see
now through just winning something
happens to Magnus and with simple moves
like taken D7 go Knight F3
or d5d5 Knight F3 even and played the
same game which is like better for you
in any imaginable way right right it's
the pawn structure for black that's
terrible terrible exactly exactly and
for Magnus I mean okay he really got
rocked losing with the white pieces in
round four against Bobby and under 20
moves well actually it went longer than
that but it was a winning position at 20
uh to
to potentially losing back-to-back games
well we that's so if anyone can save
this game it is Magnus exactly uh
jumping by the way to the game between
Richie and nepo because they went right
down that uh pathway with Bishop E6
pardon me we're still on the game with
Magnus said Bishop E6 Bishop takes
Knight takes and I think this is really
shows great judgment by Napo to not take
the Rook on D1 but to take the bishop
and just say look I'm a pawn up and you
know it's a two result game
and look at this I mean when you know
you've got the doubled Rooks on the side
wow it just it just feels like
everything that's a little bit
in-game technique it should be a winning
end game it should be a winning ending
and the the time of course Nepal has 22
minutes on his clock he plays so fast
and the rich is down to four minutes
exactly a game that kind of got away
from us a little bit is the game between
Ivan sarich and Jan Duda uh Duda in
second place just behind Vichy did
sacrifice the pawn uh but got the two
Bishops
opposite color
but I was going to say Black's pieces uh
really standing very well yeah if that
black Rook gets to E2 yeah hello you
know and the other one is ready to join
its colleague on H2 so for example Rook
D1 let's just put some moves on the
board and this is where we're talking
about the active black Brooks something
like this I just wanted to put this on
the board as really a great compensation
Bishops of opposite color and the just
you've got this great Rook on the
seventh rank that's not going to lose
this position
absolutely
alireza Magnus Magnus didn't want to go
into the ending because she still went
into
vert in it that was the exchange
Constantine dropping in exchange after
Knight F3 and just as uh Miro was saying
in the game of uh farusia and Magnus
Magnus avoided the queen trade but there
goes G5 like that's a huge slurp now I
think Queen B3 is coming with the
Checkmate thread because Magnus played
Rook d8
forcing us to make a deadly threat of
mate in one and I guess we've got to
defend the threat and maybe one
everything about such a position
you know like yeah it's repulsive to me
uh black structure is
damaged let's not forget white already
has an extra Pawn too the extra pawn and
the superior Superior position I would
just put it like that Queen B3 Rook D1
plays itself uh farouza is looking very
good Mara I want to send it back over to
you and tell us about our tournament
leader
yes uh not much to talk here
interestingly Vichy has found the idea
well in a little bit different uh moves
order but he did go King to B6
when C5 and then said I'll be waiting
for you to capture on C5 H4 and then
brought the Knight to C6 so you're gonna
have to
King to E3 B4 off goes another Pawn
Knight to D4 Knight to C6 right and yeah
you can go back and then black can also
go back or you trade are the the Knight
of the bishop black won't lose I mean
okay maybe
let's just quickly show this line Bishop
H3 Knight takes you in order to play for
win you need an extra pawn and then you
don't need to but you know it's a nice
picturesque move G5
and you can't do absolutely nothing
right yeah an extra Pawn it's like it's
just he's done it he's taken on easy
yeah he's taken only six so we are going
this route
uh just to say that kukash
not a good day not a good day day one
but uh things are definitely looking up
here in day two as he's taken a he's won
the exchange well
a blunder uh by Constantine and he is
sometimes you need those little gifts
from your opponent yes yes I I've always
said this uh that you know it's very
very hard to win a tournament and you
know we say in chess you can't get lucky
but actually we know that you can and
you need to get lucky uh in chess uh to
win a tournament and uh uh up in
exchange and there's a tactic in the
position I just wanted to show exchange
and the pawn and a pond and a good
position but there's this nice little
tactic that would go for example Rook A4
and if you took on A5 it's like you're
Bishops that is pretty
so everything's going very very nice for
how old is gukash by the way he's so
young I think he's 17.
17. I was a wow 17 years young and yeah
I I met him for the first time in
Dusseldorf in February or February of
this year and just a very very pleasant
young man and he was showing us his game
that he played he was showing and what
he sees at the board is incredible he's
a he's a really outstanding calculator
he is the 2018 World Champion for youth
at 17 years old one of the
wow Nepal has already won his game two
in a row well that's well good for him
much more than he expects and by the way
that really knocks Richie backwards
because Richie was having a very good uh
day one and in the tournament with
double scoring system yes the standings
can change so fast exactly and it was
really this up to this moment Richie had
actually played a very good game but he
here he errored it was Bishop to G4 he
took on G6 he took yeah that was the
error and then things kind of just right
here
and we have a draw between Vichy
and Fabi as this result provisioning
absolutely with the black pieces yeah
making a solid draw
yeah another handshake here but in this
case a handshake in favor of gukesh
and then we have magnus's game
still looking very good for ferocia
exactly by the way uh and after Bishop
D2 a gookish played a move that I think
is a really good good one for amateur
players especially and for professional
players too I like the decision to play
Rook B2 to simplify to give back the
exchange to get back the material but to
simplify the position and look at the
resulting position
extra material coupons for Black
possibly three very soon but yes exactly
active very good passive passive active
all of Black's pieces looking really
really good and after Rook D1 G6 just
avoid the back rank Checkmate and the
threat and it just it's terrible it's
it's it's gone essentially this game so
go cash on his way to Victory Miro back
over to you tell us about dudas game all
right so do this game and this
interesting like really really not that
easy to understand Burlington might be
you know an interesting lesson on
positional play because well let's first
show what happens now right that that's
the that's the current position very
active black Rooks full compensation for
the pawn I believe uh he will have no
difficulties making a draw
and if we step a little bit backward
after a perhaps after age five here
it's very tempting to maintain the
structure that's what even sarich did he
played F3 right however it was more
important to take on H5 and if Rook
takes back to play H4 so you have no
issues on the H file right and then it's
more of a dynamical type of position
where black actually has to spend two
more moves to return the Rook back
and you still have an extra Pawn with
white you still have some potential
targets like this Pawn on C7 for
instance by the way just to interrupt
you we do have the result uh that we
expected gookash has won our
congratulations to him Miro please do
continue sorry to interrupt you right
yeah so anyway I think that was that was
a missed opportunity and now it looks oh
well in fact computer still uncertain
sometimes shifts into a wide's favor but
yeah if the king F1 he can just capture
Rook captures you can take on F3 if
Bishop captures
you perhaps you can take on H4 but
computer goes A4 first it's less and
less pawns on the board the opposite
colored Bishops whenever Rooks are
traded it's an immediate draw right yeah
Duda saves it which brings us to what
situation in the cross table and I'm
still in the lead
in the lead but for Duda uh should he
win he could catch Anand a draw and he
will be a point behind again because of
the double point system that would be a
huge surprise yeah
uh when we left it we really expected uh
the move Queen B3 uh kind of shocking
that he didn't play it because Queen B3
obviously comes with the thread of
Checkmate kind of puts additional
pressure on the B6 Bond Queen C2 is
perugia's Choice and then there was a
trade of knights on H4 and quickly we're
getting to the pla current position uh
an extra Pawn for white but
still there's quite a lot of work I want
to say that has to be done I mean I'm
very very happy to be white king is
still not the safest which right now
it's safe but eventually it will be a
problem true but your extra Pawn your
majority you know what I'm saying you're
not really putting it uh to work so to
speak and
okay uh converting it how are you going
to convert it maybe you're going to try
to just exchange all the pieces and go
into the end game
Bishop versus knight extra Pawn should
be winning
not clear not for me not for me I I I'm
thinking as black if you if you if you
start to try to trade off all of the
Rooks uh exactly how you're going to use
your extra Pawns
I don't know uh is it going to be so
easy for you to to to to convert
I don't know uh
but if you could play G3 and F4 as we
take a look at the lifetime score
between now this is a uh more lopsided I
want to say it's a total of 20 games 10
draws and
15 wins for Magnus if
five losses right sorry 30 Games total
yeah uh three to one
Victory ratio four magnets Magnus just
played the move Queen C4 by the way uh
provoking b2b3 uh as you probably drop
back with the screen can you play Bishop
again you're happy you're a happy camper
game will be over much sooner than we
expected
uh true that uh wow uh how does black
keep the D file here can't right I'm
looking at your move Bishop B6 and I'm
thinking
why did I allow why did I play Queen
Magnus
Miro this move Queen C4 looks just wrong
right you are yes and and the move is
wrong it's just wrong I mean on a lot of
counts it's interesting what happened
during those last few moves because yes
indeed White's position is still better
however in terms of converting the
advantage he kind of made a few steps
back right because when you were
discussing it here indeed Queen B3
followed by Rook a D1 and so on it was
kind of more energetic and it was very
close to being a forced win well
somewhere here after Bishop F2 as you
correctly pointed out there is job to be
done however with Queen C4 if he finds I
don't know if he did play it not yet
Bishop B6 it does improve the White
Edition already good White's position it
does improves it great deal right fakes
now let's find out together what happens
if you take on A2 it's interestingly not
even a check but Queen D3 is very strong
you want to give a check with with the
queen
so perhaps black has to take action
against this one like King G6 and then
you are free to take the pawn on B5 by
the way
he played B3 yeah he played B3 and C6
Bishop E3 is the current position but
here nothing changed it's still uh much
better for white probably winning
objectively and still some job to be
done it will not win itself but uh By
the way when Magnus saw the move B3 he
played Queen 66 so quickly it was like
he was so happy to stop Bishop V6 I mean
I think he almost made a smile and uh
well he's he's the one chopping the
Rooks off the board uh you know normally
when you're behind material you're
trying to keep uh the the bits but yes I
guess now we'll see how to win this end
game yeah exactly and again it's not if
it's in my eyes it's not that easy
you're going to your your
majority your extra Pawn is on the king
side and I think you're going to need to
play the moves G3 and F4 and the Knight
and the queen are going to make that a
little bit difficult difficult exactly
exactly
uh again Miro I mean you you have a
great deal of experience and you know
what it's like you know fighting a pawn
down or a pawn up and objectively how
would you
percentage-wise would you say white will
win this you know a hundred percent of
the time
for sure no 100 for sure and
specifically for this match for for this
pair
I would bet that we will see a bit of
Magnus magic and he's going to save even
though yeah there is no doubt
objectively the position is winning
right but I really like what ferrusha
just did with biplane C4 I think his
next move is going to be Queen D5 Queen
to David five that's an improvement yeah
okay just a second so we can
think the king a little bit closer to
the center first yeah yeah then we had
to start to think as as black where do
we want our Knight he's played the move
19 to D6
uh provoking C5 yes and now the question
is where do we want our Knight I mean
objectively where is that our our best
Square back to F7 and just Queen D5 now
looks very good okay of course Black's
not going to touch that no and you know
any Queen trades would get me in will
get me fired uh how about Queen to B5 he
didn't he played King H2 Magnus by the
way
what's the clock time so I'm going to
stop by two minutes so six and a half
for Magnus and four and a half for
feroza but uh against I I want to say
Magnus is making some very very crucial
decisions Miro as if yes bang bang bang
this is absolutely he's making these
critical moves A4 Knight D6 very quickly
very quickly remarkably fast yeah that's
probably reflection of of uh what he
feels about about this game about this
current position right right so it
sometimes feels a bit unfair how quickly
your position got that bad right uh King
H2 by the way uh and I think allocation
of maybe Queen D5 King G3 King H4 I was
considering going to H4 but it's so
risky well so long as you don't get
mated you know like that then it'll be
fine
um
okay uh objectively the estimation of
the engines uh Miro is plus eight three
plus plus three three five and plus 2.8
with King G3 which may break down to the
same thing yes King G3 Queen D5 King H4
and if you can play G4 and establish a
past H Pawn then I think your winning
chances just go through the roof oh all
right there is another interesting
maneuver yasa maybe you could show it on
the board to have the queen D5 Queen B5
which probably is gonna be instantly
there is Bishop F2 Bishop H4 an
interesting you know very nice
transferring the bishop to H4 and then
you always threatening some Queen E6 and
stuff yes you are yeah maybe a four in
the right moment there and he spotted
your spot on Bishop F2 Bishop H4 and
then you've got this queen E6 in your
pocket do you see why I picked ferocious
for for this one moment I I see why you
picked for Rouge it was it was a great
choice yeah for that one moment yeah he
took about a minute
and found this beautiful idea and now it
feels more pressure for sure well indeed
the queen on D5 versus the queen on B5
this uh you know understanding the
battlefield the chess board and you
understand what primary squared Prime
squares are for the pieces uh D5 E5 F5
C5 are all prime squares for the queen
that's when the queen is at her most
majestic best and so once the bishop
comes to H4 should Magnus just put the
Quinn back to C6 he's going to have to I
don't think there's going to be a choice
about it in that particular case though
I do see the the um if he goes for
counter attack like Queen B2 I don't see
any kind of attack no that's the other
beautiful point about the queen on D5
not only is it great as far as attacking
potential is concerned hello hello there
is one funny way not to resign
immediately and that's Knight h8
Knight h8 to meet yeah to meet Bishop
h46 I don't trust it I don't think it
holds but that's what one of the moves
of the computer it's still that lost for
black but right at least see you have an
option to meet uh we might see that yeah
we you desperate desperate uh moments
call for assessment measures but you
know I always think that if I play a
move like Knight h8 you know the the
feed a is going to
un award me my Grandmaster title they're
going to take it away and say you know
you don't deserve your title after uh
what if it's computers first move yeah
then I guess to make an exception but
Knight h8 I
I like it I like it what else can I do
there's no other ideas for black there's
no uh the other remaining game of doodad
let's just check in very quickly because
it has changed well I wanted to say that
a great deal is cheap oh Black's King is
very active that's the great that's the
big deal that has changed and I think
with this last moves by the way it's
kind of an indication that Yvonne sarich
is you know when you play a move like
Rook D3 and you know I've got this Rook
G2 uh
it's almost like white is trying to keep
the position he's not trying to improve
the position he's trying to keep his
position and I don't think dude is in
any trouble anymore I think any uh
yeah he's down
so good I think black's the only one who
would try something he starts I think
yeah of course it should be easily
holdable well yeah it's about if I can
activate
just magically uh drop in on G2 it'd be
Checkmate uh
F4 was an impatient move he could have
could have keep the advantage with King
G2 Rook F2 and so on but after F4 King
G4 it really computer says it's equal
which means well from you know from
practical standpoint you probably prefer
black bite right unless he repeats the
moves right by the way with the move
rugby to check rookie to Rook B1
an invitation uh for Yvonne to play
uh
what well not rookie three but not
rookie five but rookie three rookies
yeah working maybe in a little bit of
trouble for sure uh it might induce me
to play the move Rook F5 but I I like
that I like the
rugby to check one here King E1 or G1 E1
and then I have to
take
um measures and play rookies
Rook E7
okay I might grab another point
yes uh funny funny funny funny I guess
G6 rookie said huh
I don't have any way of really punishing
you it looks strange we have E4 here
right the strange Photoshop F3
yeah I could still be fine just because
their pieces are so active exactly
especially this King on G4 but rookie
five Magnus played Knight AJ night in
shape they then take away his title
h8 and F4 uh
so and future played F4 within five
seconds I think so he was expecting this
Knight h8 so they both saw this move
exactly so F4 uh an indication that uh
you can take on F4 I could consider E5
as well as Queen takes H5 but f4 on the
board
I guess you have to play Knight G6 right
if takes e is forced
five you I thought a five didn't help me
and Knight F4 me oh pardon me uh Queen
F1 sorry uh I I was thinking the Knight
might get a little bit trapped but
that's not the case Effie yes
and I guess I have to take with the
Knight and something like Bishop D4
Bishop to D4 yeah that's that's great
okay Magnus came up with something else
after F4 Queen to B2
tickling the bishop Bishop G3
looks like a big move
now if you play 96 Queen D7 looks
unpleasant
true that King H6 are you mating me I I
mean I feel like I no I I mean I'm
taking Bishop you want some more or
order that yeah it should it should be
uh farouza's uh party Bishop G3 Knight
can go back to F7 it's more safe
protect the seventh rank
yes
I guess I should take on E5 and then
still Bishop for Bishop H4
ah sorry you mean after Knight F7 take
on E5 and then come up with some ideas
with queen E6 Bishop H4 looks good he
has captured on F4 by the way
okay it is time a factor between Knight
F7 so Magnus has one minute and 30
seconds and feroza has two and a half
minutes
so one minute ahead on on the clock as
well so it's time and position and H5 is
H5 for A2
I wouldn't want to give uh
that kind of counter play uh to but at
the same time if we don't tell me how
I'm supposed to win it Miro Jump Right
In on this one uh
some kind of a little Fortress set up
Magnus is doing his best not a fortress
but indeed as you've mentioned you have
to take on H5 you have to find carriage
in and this wins for sure but if you're
a computer of course right because
otherwise it looks fairly dangerous
and now Queen G4 for whatever reason is
the only move that wins but it wins
uh sure enough because here Queen D7 and
perhaps the B one is always drop some
still not convinced yeah if Queen B3 is
played I and then using the fact that
the Knight is pinned we go E5 you open
up everything and then the a44 pawn is
no longer threatening because the bishop
controls it and the king is in the open
okay it's not that easy to spot right
and right do something else like
computer says Bishop E3 it's one plus
1.7 less than two pawns even though it
used to be three Pawns in firge's favor
but that's shocking for me because the
move Bishop E3 is actually I find that
move attractive I want to put the bishop
on D4 right and uh let's see why and if
I could play bishop and he's played
Bishop E3 uh even Queen E5 I'll be sure
nice is that easily winning with Knight
jumping around it probably is before
because of Knight F3 he played Knight E5
right away by the way Queen E5 check I
agree with you some checks yes yes and
Bishop F4 three results yeah Bishop D4
Knight F3 3 results
oops
uh but he played 95 right away and
Bishop went back to F4 and Knight F7 but
he doesn't have to move the Knight right
he could just live it because the queen
ending yeah H4 is what computer suggests
and maybe for a good reason because look
now let's say if you take black cannot
swap the Queens but takes like this
there is always a hope yeah there's
always a hope this guy is weak right
you'll probably put the phone on A3
happily and say you're extra Pawn on G2
is a shelter but it's not winning
no this is excellent uh chances are to
hold I would say very very good chances
from practical standpoint that the best
he can do A3 by the way he did not play
H4 but he's inviting the ending we're
discussing uh yeah but okay you have to
be computed to see this one because now
I'm not sure if it will be played but
computer was fighting against King G3
and that was Queen Bean centralized
perhaps the king marches all the way the
engine says plus five almost yeah right
here it's plus five but after and he's
done it instead if he would have played
H4 that would be far less and also not
that easy to convert King G3 nope
Kings you through is not an obvious move
at all and believe it or not after H4
it's equal I don't know I I cannot
believe it but it says it's equal if
black plays H4 the moment you pick my H4
Pawn I'm capturing A2 exactly wow it's
really that simple and that was why King
G3 and he's an H4 is on the board that
was why King G3 was absolutely vital and
how we raise a missed
that close and you relax for one little
bit
and he's gone what's remarkable is to go
from
-5 to even in one move on one move where
you don't capture anything not a blunder
and it doesn't look like a blender
minus five to even sometimes it's good
that you don't know
right you know because if you felt like
you had just given away the whole point
with one move you would feel depressed
Queen G4 check and hold on let me just
okay yes sir yes quick question to you
yes sir you have few seconds King F7 or
King f8
you know at this moment I'm not sure or
I I know the difference uh
probably King F7 yeah by the way a draw
a very happy looking players uh both
sides seem relieved King F7 was played
was played and there is absolutely it
was a mistake
that's the losing move that's the losing
move right I'm not sure if what happened
okay let's let's drop compute Evolution
because now if it does
H7
which is exactly what so that's why we
had to have our kids it was better no
that's absolutely crazy and queen's
impossible
impossible so are we going to see fork
no we're not going to see so this is
winning just because of c67 or yeah it
looks like you cannot really Force
uh yeah so normal scenario would be your
a pawn is getting too close and white is
forced to give a Perpetual but after
c6a2 black
first
A5 like behind the possible and and I
think oh and then I have two extra pawns
yes yeah two extra pawns uh by the way
that is not your vertical hold that
sometimes on those uh televisions you
had these vertical holds that you had to
adjust your knob that's actually just
the India it was the only move to win
and it was played in the second exactly
Queen d8 so he needs to just put the
queen on the right Square to avoid the
Perpetual yes and then just push to
seven exactly wow wow
still not over
but there's a lot of twists and turns
still to go in this one I'm afraid too
uh Miro these Queen endings they have
their own rules I want to say that are
very very very different than normal
chess
uh rules right I'm still trying to
comprehend the difference between King
f8 King F7 and and how realistic was you
know to find it by the way Magnus down
to 16 seconds for Rouge has just played
Queen G8 with 45 seconds on his clock
and he's going to play Queen to f a
check as you said 10 places to avoid any
perpetuals
does black have any more tricks well you
don't want to play King E6 and allow uh
promotion with checks so I see four
coins on the board yeah
and a very naked black king king G6 on
the board and well C7 I think that's
just resigns
and you and there's the handshake and
it's Magnus uh we do not say this very
often as Magnus loses back to back two
games defeats and look at the there's a
kind of a look of shock on magnus's face
right she's listening to Big Applause
for furusia from the audience but look
at him he is just he's kind of taser
like he he's missed something
he's probably figured out that King f8
was a draw
wow
uh Miro
sum up yet another remarkable uh
round of play wow these five games the
the first set of five games were amazing
this one uh I'm a little bit shocked
okay so good cash opens his scoreboard
right right against the police code that
was a relatively easy one NEPA continues
to win I mean that's why the guy was
asking how to win one in a row because
he knows how to win the other ones right
well it turns so and then we just
witnessed Magnus losing I mean and it's
kind of the most painful game I believe
he sort of lost twice right he almost
battled his way out of it and if you
love him just quickly we all seen what
happened after King F7 yet sculptures
sculptures a check and the pawn was gone
and hence king of f8 was better because
it's not that easy to tell Queen takes
Queen takes and for a brief moment even
though you're pawned down you can go to
the you know to those those kind of end
games you can block with the queen
because your Pawn is too dangerous
exactly and this is how you not lose
wow not the end game magic that you
predicted but here are our standings
after five rounds of Rapids
the tournament with eight points
and point behind young Crystal studio
and with plus one Fabiano caruan or post
tuna
Fabiano caruana and Yani promise
yeah plus one
and let's check in uh with Christian in
Zagreb Christian over to you
I have to say guys uh Ali Reza just
played an amazing end game with only a
few seconds on the clock and I think
this was a pivotal moment in that end
game and you were mentioning Mira what
happened after the move uh C6 what if I
go A2 and just push my pawn and you said
that he's going to go Queen A5 go behind
the pawn and this would be winning but
in fact this was not the solution
because after Queen wave 5 I can simply
just take on C6 if you do take my pass
Pawn the pawn on A2 I'm going to take on
e4 and despite the fact that you have
disconnected passers it's all about that
e-pawn and in fact the table base is
saying that this position is a draw but
take a look at this instead of this
after A2 Queen to E3 was the move that
you open the diagonal A7 to G1 you have
to understand this In the Heat of the
battle and this is exactly what Ali Reza
did with his last move this move C6
Queen to E3 you cannot touch the f file
as black if you go King to F6 hey guess
what I'm going to go Queen to F2 and
that's going to touch the pawn on A2
next I'm going to go C7 and uh this is
going to be all she wrote for example if
you go queen king to E6 excuse me I'm
going to go C7 right now now you get the
queen A1 Queen but I have Queen to F5
and I'm going to get a queen as well we
have Four Queens on the board after King
to D6 C8 Queen and this is just simply
going to be winning for white because I
have two extra pawns and you cannot get
to my king in time if you would be able
to fly a queen to G1 well that would be
good for you and probably that would
allow you to at least make a draw but
unfortunately that's not how chess works
so this would have been the winnings uh
sequence for white very very intriguing
end game in this one and I want to show
you a critical moment in nepo's game as
well because the opening phase
specifically in this one was very
interesting and take a look at the time
as well uh displayed uh right there
Nepal with 26 minutes at this point this
is move up
16 and he still has 26 minutes on the
clock F4 Knight to C6 and F5 and I have
to say this looks very dangerous for
black because I'm threatening F6 and
Checkmate after Queen to H6 you're in
big trouble you have to defend a certain
way and this was the critical moment in
Nepal in fact spent about a minute and a
half and played the move F6 right idea
wrong execution because he could have
gotten in trouble after this move F6
what he had to do and most likely this
was in his preparation as well was to
take on F5 first and then play the move
F6 it looks dangerous for the King on G7
but I have a lot of counter play given
by my d-pawn and my very powerful Center
as black I'm going to go D5 next move
and that's going to allow me to get a
lot of compensation for my weak King
instead of that he played the move F6
this was a critical moment because White
had a great move at his disposal and
that was was Bishop to G4 I can play the
move Bishop to G4 now I'm threatening to
take on G6 and this is a very minute
detail in this one for example if you go
something along the lines of Knight to
D4 I'm going to take you're going to
take I'm going to exchange the Bishops
very important and after Knight to G4
you have a huge difficulties defending
the king side Queen to H6 is a big
problem so if you allow my knight to
land on G4 then the black king is going
to be in trouble on G7 that's why you
have to exchange the light Square
Bishops that's uh what Richie Rapport
missed and by the way if you go G5
unfortunately that's going to give me a
free attack on the king side you no
longer have that threatening Center in
the absence of the Pawn on e4 the pawn
on e4 is still uh there to um pretty
much block your expansion in the center
and in the meantime I'm just going to go
Knight to F3 H4 next move I'm going to
Target that pawn G5 open up the H file
and most likely Checkmate you on the H
file big missed opportunity for Richie
report but as you guys were mentioning
nepo is stringing some victories
together and let's take a look at the
standings after round five here in
zagram because there's some movement at
the top still vishyanan with eight
points leading the tournament of Duda
with seven points in second position and
we see Jan was struggling after day one
he was asking how am I winning one game
in a row well what is better than one
win in a row two wins in a row and
that's exactly what he got standing at
six points right now definitely In
Contention we're going to go on a short
break and Anastasia actually caught up
with the players take a look
[Music]
foreign
it's one of the best chess players of
the world a lot of Chess fans view as a
role model what would you like your
impact to be
I love chess and I think chess is a fun
game so I just hope to have inspired
more people to to play I hope to just
play some good games and always play
fighting games and
yeah I I hope to I hope that fans will
enjoy my games and
yeah it'll be nice interacting with the
fans here as well uh I want I would like
them to enjoy chess just to to play I
mean just to go on and
either on internet or just with a friend
just enjoy just
can't really thought about it
but I think
I want that young players that they
somehow learn to play that they have the
fighting spirit that
they need to also learn how to deal with
losses and victories as well so
you need to be
not the same but let's say you know
don't you need to deal well with the
losses as well
I haven't really thought about it much
about my
just as being a role models to someone
else I just try to improve it
for myself and for my play
um I think everybody should take their
listen from each players in for instance
when I was growing up I was learning
from Magnus live on like I was looking
at them carefully and I was learning so
I like to like I'm playing a risky chess
so I like people to watch me and uh see
that even if you play risketches
nowadays it's still going to work so
yeah that's maybe one of the things I
like to be
well it's uh
I know I know you know with some some
people they sort of like following and
trying to
uh I don't know would say to imitate or
something yeah but uh I don't think it's
my zone of responsibility I'm just
trying to be let's say uh like a nice
person and uh yeah
sometimes also a nice player but I think
this is not not as important yeah I hope
I'll Inspire some young players to pick
up the game or if they're new to the
game to uh to stick with it to improve
even if they're not don't become
professional chess players at least to
keep it as like a lifelong hobby or
something that they always keep in their
life I think that's a good thing and
especially these days we're seeing more
and more popularity
um and I don't know exactly what the
reason for the reason is for the the
recent growth let's say the last four
years there could be a big combination
of things uh but I'm I hope that in some
part I also play at least a small part
in improving the popularity of the game
and bringing new people to it well I
hope there are not too many you know
um yeah I I I don't really know I mean
when it comes to having role modelers
and chess
um I feel like when you're you know for
kids it's very useful and just to have
someone to look forward to but I'm not
so sure if my style is most suited for
that purpose and otherwise I try to be
you know just a good person a good human
being which I feel like everyone should
aspire to be so in the trigger I don't
feel like again anything special about
me and
um
yeah but you know like I said
earlier in early interviews I feel like
chess is a little bit of reflection of
who we are and everyone should bring
something unique so I really hope that
the future Generations will find ways to
also make an impact in chess and to to
bring something special from from yeah
I'm not sure I uh like um
like don't really consider things you
know in such in such way and
um yeah I'm happy you know to entertain
people to some extent and
um maybe gather them some inspiration
I mean mostly important of course
but um
yeah but I said I don't really think
that way and um yeah it's nice that you
know making popular stress a little bit
but a part of that I guess there are
better role models in than me so um
I would
hopefully
they would feel good about playing chess
and hopefully they're getting some
positive vibes from me that um
you know just is a wonderful activity
first of all a lot of fun but also
develop some very healthy qualities and
things like that and hopefully I'm an
advertisement for that
[Music]
it's time to fight for titles the best
juniors girls and Senior chess players
converge in the chess capital of America
St Louis Missouri for the U.S junior
girls and Senior championship
beginning July 15th 30 players will
compete across three fields for over a
150 000 prize fund
this tournament features the top Junior
and senior chess players in the nation
including the young up-and-comer Karissa
yip
Young Junior Phenom ABI Manu Mishra and
returning senior Champion Alexander
shavalov
three titles are on the line and you
won't want to miss it catch all the
action on the St Louis chess club
YouTube and twitch channels
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States we
bring the educational benefits of Chess
to thousands of students across the St
Louis area we also promote Chess at the
highest levels hosting all levels of the
U.S championships as well as high
profile tournaments that attract the
world's best players become a member and
enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why Jess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game the World Chess Hall
of Fame has something for everyone to
enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chess sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
[Music]
it's your move the muni premiere of
Chess plays the muni through July 11th
sponsored by St Louis chess club and the
World Chess Hall of Fame for
ticketsmuni.org
foreign
chess club is the Premier chess facility
in the United States and is among the
best in the world thanks to co-founders
Dr Jeannie Karen sinkfield and Rex
sinkfield the St Louis chess club is a
non-profit organization committed to
promoting the game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomed
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
posting all levels of the U.S
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sync field cup
Cairns cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over 2
000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
[Music]
hello and welcome back and here are our
standings after five very exciting
rounds of Rapid Nasi do the honors
with eight points closely following just
one point behind Jan Christoph Duda
right and with plus one scores Fabiano
caruana and Yani publishing yarn coming
from nowhere and tell us about the round
six pairings
wow we have this girlfriend playing with
Shannon the ultimate matchup right there
two ex-world Champions uh Duda against
Carolina kokesh is playing sarich the
publisher playing lupulasco and ferrugia
reports uh Napo a potential six out of
six for this uh day two and farouja can
he do it for Magnus look at the scores
between Magnus and Magnus has a little
bit of a black magic I want to say over
vishy if you saw that Global chess game
incredible they're Head to Head their
head to head a lot of games 29 draws but
23 wins for Magnus and only 12 wins for
a man a near two to one ratio and Miro
weigh in on these two Gladiators uh well
there's a lot of intrigue in this last
round right I mean I would say it's an
ultimate test for an ant if it was a
different Magnus because the Magnus is
kind of falling apart however he might
have a special motivation against Rishi
then there is firuja playing Rapport if
I'm not mistaken yeah so that's very
important for the part of the standings
and then nepo has a chance with white
against lupulasco to become Real Hero of
the Day winning all three games
absolutely but fight per second between
Duda and Fabi oh yeah also that becomes
a a huge pretty cool game yeah huge
Clash for this our last round of the
Rapids and in their head to head how do
they match up uh Nazi let's take a look
um not that many games
not at all but boy lopsided score yeah
only one win for Duda and five wins for
Bobby exactly Duda will be very happy to
have the white visas in this upcoming
Clash because again dude isn't clear
second and if he could take down Fabi
and push away a rival and say to Anand
I'm I'm closing in on you that that
would be huge is the only one at the
board
rest of the players have not arrived yet
exactly so get ready because just had
his first win in the tournament
he'll try for a second he's with white
against Ivan sarich today started with a
bang four out of five games were
decisive and it looked like it could
easily have been five for five in that
game between gookash and Richie Richie
missing a chance at the very end then
seeing Magnus tumble in back-to-back
losses we were having this conversation
when was the last time that happened and
only time we can think of was a half an
hour ago exactly that is exactly uh how
Mira put it to us
it was just minutes ago so we're gonna
ask our production
to answer that question when did Magnus
lose back to back games might have been
on a grand chest tour somewhere it might
have been in a blitz of one of the blitz
that it's such a rarity to speak of it
definitely not last Blitz when he won 10
games in a row
exactly as we see vishy at the board
leading the competition
uh nobody saw that coming
but let's take a look at Maggie's
tournament so far it's not been a thing
of beauty
two wins and two losses
this is no one win uh he won one you oh
yeah two two points yeah he started with
a win and we said okay this is the
Maggie we all know but look at that two
draws again it's the two point and then
two losses good thing there is no such
result as minus one because if you pay
attention to the Dynamics it's not very
promising right
and the contrast couldn't be more visual
than this started with a draw one three
in a row and another draw against Fabi
in the last round right and for Vichy
he's getting the two blacks uh in a row
in a row
right and talk about uh getting tested
in
so we just heard that Tata steel this
year Magnus lost two games in a row
to giri and another back
wow I remember he lost but I didn't know
that it was back to back it it didn't
register with me either wow okay well
thank you to our production uh for that
and I suspect it was Dennis who came up
with that but that uh
yeah Miro I mean it's a little bit
shocking we should have remembered the
talk to steal but somehow uh we forgot
about it the games are underway uh
Magnus arriving probably about 30
seconds late I want to say because I am
I am getting other moves for example
typically fashionably right and we've
got the Karo Khan again
well it worked very well uh for Vichy
his game against Magnus was it highly
doubt we were going to see the fantasy
variation again exactly D4 D5 F3 I
wonder if Magnus even had any time to
look at their last game between Fabian
Anand to prep against caracon
probably not because magnus's game went
the longest right
well Magnus I think still is kind of
like uh wounded he because he's not
looking like somebody who has won the
world championships for Less 17 years
those two have been the world champions
17 or 16 something like that
not bad
let's say they've dominated for the last
two decades I think you'd be right
um Bishop D3 okay exchange variation The
Exchange variation uh still underrated
uh a very very popular from the times of
uh Jose row capablanca and I remember
there was a game here at a U.S
Championship where it was like E5
like I've played this my whole career
and then uh somebody I think it was a
Wonder Liang it was like Bishop F4 and
E5
yeah it was Sam Shanklin and
that that they played it very fast and I
was like wait a minute all my life I
played the Karo Khan and they played a
variation I've never seen before by the
way Knight C6 Bishop D Knight C6 C3 all
very standard and you're supposed to
when you're playing the Karo Khan as
opposed to the French defense the the
the goal of the Karo Khan is to get your
Bishop out and you usually play Knight
F6 to do that E7 E6 right away
that is a really a
for me that's a stunning move and wasn't
it the world championship match
where it was like Bishop D7
there was a nepo it was like what hello
E7 E6 Bishop F4 Bishop D6
trade seeing the database one game by
Carlson with the black pieces this exact
position with the black pieces wow
marrow uh picked this up and tell us for
for me E7 E6 is not in my
repertoire knowledge base right you are
it's a rare move according to the
database and I was actually surprised to
see it much more popular choices being
of course Knight to F6 a queen to C7
however if you click on E6 and brow
through the names you can see Fabiano
caruana Carlson Anand and so on and so
forth so apparently it's something new
that players figured out is playable and
play against each other and so far after
Bishop F4 Bishop D6 and the trade and
you still have all those names yes
Carson's game with black popped up
Knight to F3 and the whole point is to
put the Knight to E7
right so if we are thinking Carlsbad
structure with colors reversed and for
whatever reason this bishop being stuck
on C8 instead of being on G4 as you are
just requested it to be right castles
castles well computer slightly favors
white no surprises here and we are
limited to three games in the database
which seen this which reached this
position Queen C2 or rookie one being
the moves
exactly and I suppose that from the
current position we have to say rookie
one uh sorry uh castles castles uh Rook
E1 I suppose the idea is that eventually
black is playing for F7 F6 rookie eight
and one
fine day
eventually eventually F6 E5 and the
bishop will be liberated but instead of
the move rookie one I like what you had
proposed Mira which was the question I
want to know what you're going to do I
just wanted yeah you go ahead play H6 I
understand go ahead and play G6 I
understand but I just like to to clarify
are you playing for
right what are you playing for over here
can I play H6 then your idea with F6
would be yes not as good exactly exactly
it Minx makes uh H6 and F6 less
desirable but rookie one was uh magnus's
Choice uh
and uh it's still in the database as far
as your your database goes uh Miro uh
sorry uh the rookie one was the last
move that I sure could find and it's one
game one game and not very high level
okay you have another game in front of
you I was looking at Ali Reza's game
against Richard Robert
and yeah you would expect this right
Knight to F6 tonight's defense and well
I just have to say it's a Pity nobody
goes Knight G5 with crazy complications
nowadays D3 and then a bit of a surprise
Bishop to E7
uh which isn't the most popular choice
but perfectly sound and from kind of big
names of the past
whoa what what was that I think uh we
just heard that Magnus is having chair
problems right
so they're really changing the channel
right it's clear that Magnus is not
comfortable at all right
could it be the chair or the results I
think uh the results
but go ahead please uh two two nights
nobody's playing Nigeria back today two
nights and then Bishop E7 from Big names
I can recall of the past I can recall
billersky doing this instead of Bishop
C5 so Knight to C3 d70s Knight C3 by the
way is not the most popular people still
prefer usually to keep it in Joko piano
slash rui Lopez type of positions with
C3 probably Castle short and then later
on C3 so Knight C3 D6 A3 now you need to
prepare the square for this bishop
otherwise Knight A5 at some point
castles H3 Bishop E6 plain and simple so
he's not trying to invent
anything just you want to trade trade
Knight to D5 since Ali Reza A5 castles
A4
this is where we lost it I think now A5
was the first independent move right
Knight D5 was still as you can see some
games here Bishop takes was played and
some fancier moves even the move like
Rook to V8 in order to play B5 but never
A5 A5 Castle day four oops
Miss clicking Bishop A2 and plays on
their own computer favors white slightly
and the funny part is one of the moves
it suggests is going back to C8 with the
bishop in order to be able to take on E5
with the Knight yes that that's you
don't want to capture with the bishop I
suspect because this happens and then D4
and the bishop might look passive for
now but then the C Pawn is going to move
and The Bishop's going to drop to B1 to
this diagonal right right he doesn't
want to take with the with the bishop
and that's why computers suggested for a
brief moment to go Bishop C8 back in
order to be able to capture with the
Knight nice uh I actually liked A5 A4
but I thought Knight C6 to A5 in this
current position Knight to six yeah to
A5 with the idea of C7 C6 and sometimes
white likes to go C3 and D4 but with the
Knight already on A5 it's kind of
discouraged C3 right once again if I'm
using the using the help of this thingy
C4 is one interesting way to play this
position yeah it is quite ambitious I
want to say because after Knight C6
right you committed sort of a positional
crime right you have your you've lost
flexibility of your queen side pawns but
yeah computer continues with some ugly
looking moves which might prove White's
Point Bishop to B1 Bishop to C2 and
maybe this A4 Pawn is not as safe as it
seems remarkable yeah but Knight A5 is
definitely a move to consider all right
I just wanted to turn our attention to
the game of uh nepo versus
um
Constantine for a moment uh nepo played
against the uh Sicilian these uh a Lapin
and he's building up one of these uh
attacks a king side attacks you know
it's like a slow migration towards
Black's king and queen E4
followed by Queen G4 sets up Bishop H6
positions there's usually objective
wide right in Practical game
exactly I mean the the computers are
probably saying black slightly better
slightly better but then when you get to
this position as black you start seeing
not ghosts but real threats you start
saying wait a minute I'm seeing Bishop
H6 so you get out of the way of Bishop
A6 you play King h8 then you go well
wait a minute I'm seeing the Knight
coming to E4 and then bad things might
happen the night compared to G5 the
queen and I could get mated so uh
night to I like that move it stops
Knight E4 because C4 it does it does and
the other thing I really like about that
move is if you play Bishop B3 which you
know you want to keep pieces on the
board you might see the move Queen D3
land and then you go oh that's a safety
move that that that that will really
covered Bishop E2 Bishop to E2 looks
passive but I'm stopping Queen D3 at
least for the moment that's exactly
right so here I would probably play
Knight D7 say 94. and this is the moment
you know you sit there and you go okay
you're gonna kill me and I understand
the script I'm supposed to play you know
and to it to watch you destroy me and
then I throw a move like F5 at you
and you go well I have to take take take
and you go well you're not checkmating
me anymore are you you're in position
opened up and Black's Bishops are
fantastic well yeah I mean I've
compromised my structure big time sure I
I will be the first to admit that but on
the other hand you you do get away you
you do stop the checkmating attacks so
something to think about I think that
move Knight B6 is a is an annoying move
by the way Bishop to B3 does invite
queen queen 23 Queen D3 uh for
Constantine now uh should he play it and
uh what have what's caught your eye
mirror uh well I'm back on this Magnus
versus Ceviche encounter so after rookie
won the position that was already
discussed black played F6
and it turns out C4 is the way Magnus
was planning to fight against e6e5 very
typical right he goes F6 you lose loosen
your Pawn structure a little bit and
then white uses this moment to open up
the position D takes Bishop takes and
now we are at the key kind of turning
key Point Knight F5 default Pawn is
hanging yeah you can't do much you have
to push the pawn go five and then Black
Goes Knight A5 right
and according to the machine white is
better but he has to well basically has
to sacrifice the pawn so Bishop D3 this
is a possible continuation of this line
Knight C3 Knight to C6
honestly looking at this position I
wouldn't really believe that white is
much better well compensation for the
pawn yes but it's
shifts almost to like more than half a
ball in White's favor D5 by the way on
the boards on the board talking Nero
yeah uh right I'm just looking for
alternatives for black not much of an
alternative you can't really take it
seems because after Bishop D5 King h8
white enjoys the same you know the same
kind of initiative and yeah leading
development but with even materials
right you have to play Knight A5 and get
into this position so that that's going
to be an interesting fight here
absolutely in the fight for second place
let's jump into the game between Duda
and Fabi they had a very theoretical
question I want to say they zip right
through that whole opening of the cattle
land and I think they gained a lot of
time on the clock as they were doing it
as they played a very topical line of
the open Catalan
they
I think maybe Rook A2 and move 18.
18. I like the way you do you you pegged
that I'll move 18 18 is the move 18 is
the theoretical move uh C6 E3 apparently
this position is all very well known
pundits B5 has happened
I wanted to say how can you not play the
move B5 I mean
we're taught
about the minority attack and the
minority attack
means that you must play the move B5
Rook A2 is the theoretical novelty as
you mentioned G7 G6 okay Knight D2 H5 H4
still no B5 on the board no b5s on the
board uh this move indicates to me that
Fabi is preparing to meet B5 with a b a
b and C5 yeah that's what this move
suggests to me that transposing into
isolated uh Pawn position Knight is not
great on D2 right right why why is that
why is the Knight on why why didn't he
play B5 mirror earlier and why because
it's a well not a blunder but black
takes twice and I'm acting like I'm like
it's an obvious thing but I'm as
surprised that you would be a yes so B5
yeah after Rook a to d8 right B5 right
and normally usually that's a very silly
thing to do to take twice yeah but yeah
it's a very kind of concrete
illustration B4 is a threat right so you
take it you have to take it and then
that's a brief moment where black has a
caption G3 whoa whoa whoa whoa where did
you come from so you have to take and
it's a check
and King H2 because
I imagine King H1 Queen G3 black has
enough material plus the attack right so
you don't want to go there so you go to
H2 at least to preserve the opponent and
here we go with some silly looking
Perpetual check yeah it's just a draw
wow so he's not playing B5 because he
plays for a win if you ask me and he
played Rook C2 by the way
preparing preparing
and because the queen is on B3 there's
no uh sacrifices in this case of course
because E3 is still protected does he
need to play Knight F1 and then B5 or is
that too passive just to avoid Bishop G3
ideas
yeah that's really
but I don't want to play Knight F1 yeah
and then the question is like what is
the Knight really doing on F1 anyway
just yeah kind of just defending wow I
wanted to go to uh the game of eon and
Constantine for just a moment because I
finally I found this uh moment really
surprising and Miro I mean I would have
imagined a lot of players especially
under those who are
uh The Underdogs you want to play a move
like Queen D3 just because you know in
your heart of hearts that when you play
Queen G6 you're frustrating your your
aggressive opponent why didn't he play
Queen D3 uh well dance has done I don't
know Queen D3 was a good move uh however
the move he played tends to be even
better so 97 Bishop C2 I understand
looks tempting and attacking scary but
yeah if you ask computer Queen C7 black
has the initiative because if you attack
me with Queen H3 I don't really mind
playing G6
say I can't argue with the engine but in
a rapid game the bishop is I think it's
good for white right well but there is
there is this uh discover threat right
this discovered attack our Rooks are not
developed on C1 and E1 and that's an
issue and by the way the pawn on E5 so
constantly sit there saying yeah no I
understand you're you're you know twice
world champion challenger but I can
tickle I can tickle too and this move
Bishop C2 inviting Queen C7 with this
double attack idea
what does it mean does it mean that uh
pardon me that was uh does it mean that
uh White is misplayed really he probably
has to sacrifice this Pawn so Queen to
C7 once again the line goes Queen to C7
Queen to H3 and you do not have a
comfortable way of protecting the phone
so you go Knight E4 yeah and black
captures and you play some sort of
disposition which I imagine is very
dangerous for black against nipomyoshi
because he's one very tricky player but
objectively at least computer claims
that it's not only playable but even
better for black
wow
great that's what it says fantastic
again I'm just going to check in on
vishi uh Magnus Carlson versus vishy
because vishy
uh surprising to us did not play Knight
A5 Bishop D3 and take the pawn he just
said okay go ahead play the position
that you want to play with even material
I'm ready to play Bishop D7 Rook d8
complete my development and uh do your
worst really good now
uh I'm assuming we're going to go to C7
and then Knight C5 and yeah that yeah
then I get you it sure you White's
position does play itself right
yeah uh is there a way for you to you
know it looks strange with the pawn on
F6 but uh I don't see an immediate way
of refuting maybe the setup it's very
Quincy one Queen F4 I still don't know
where I'm going from F4 but once you're
there yeah so if I just complete my
development and you put your queen on F4
is it scary
a little bit okay let's say let's say
I'm
I'm ready to to transfer my Bishop my
Bishop on D7 is passive but if I do get
it to C6 I'll be happy he did play in
the game Queen B3 by the way
and uh this is what I wanted to say that
this is really an ultimate test for
Vichy uh he gets black back-to-back
blacks against Fabi against Magnus and
against Magnus he's got this hex right
Magnus does amazing I mean
when you think about this
and is extraordinarily uh illustrious
career just imagine
you know who stopped him in World
Championships one Anatoly karpov one
Gary Kasparov and one Magnus Carlson and
if you think about History's Greatest
chess players I think I just mentioned
three names and that didn't stop him
from becoming a five-time world champion
right even though he had World
Championship matches against all three
of those opponents and the double won
against Magnus Carlson as well Queen B3
on the board Miro uh
can Magnus make anything of this moment
because if he doesn't do it I want to
say in the next five moves
vishy will will make a comfort
comfortable draw uh well according to
machine everything goes magnus's ways
really yeah as I said
since which didn't play Knight A5 I
didn't play Knight A5 yeah white enjoys
the initiative for free Knight C3 Bishop
decent Queen B3 well Machine claims to
be the best move then equally good or
rather equally bad for black was Knight
F to D4 or the move in the game Queen C7
and then interestingly I still have
trouble catching the you know what
machine
she has for white yes yeah because the
line goes h2h3 so so White's not rushing
okay after Rook E8 for instance it just
avoids trading The Rook so something in
this position maybe the bishop on D7
that you can know uh cannot really bring
to life normally
it just claims that White's better in
every possible way
but almost the pawn queen C7 no H3 Rook
D1 Rook ad1 not a bad move at all yeah
but somehow why okay I can imagine right
here right now you look at the position
and say yeah I like white I mean whites
better developed and he's got sound but
and on the other hand I'm saying well
concretely speaking I play Rook E8 or he
actually played Just Rook d8 rookie a a
d a that's z a yeah that's where she's
moved on the board
prove it yeah you're right yes in a way
that
maybe it's better for white but you
really have to be computer you have to
find all those little moves or at least
it has to be a classical game right with
a lot of time on the clock and for Rapid
for human players even the best of them
it tends to evaporate this this
Advantage right I mean you played few
moves logical moves and your opponent
did the same and it's no longer plus one
or just like marginal advantage and then
draw at the end yes I won't be surprised
if Anand will eventually equalize H2 H3
on the board and we'll keep an eye on
this one as we're going to go to the
farrugia versus uh Richie report game
because we've got that
that move uh yeah the the the the very
very ugly positional move c2c4 uh was
played the bishop on A2 is crying but
apparently it's only temporary I feel a
lot better Coach and now that you've
played C4 C5 and with the board full of
pieces was Bishop H3 on Richie's uh
agenda what do you think now see this
here yeah I don't believe that should
work no no no
you're not a True Believer
the the power of
Richie can sometimes I like what Richard
did actually exchanging enough Korean
going 94. I think why it's not forced to
but okay
I agree with you and we would also like
to trade
those but those uh D6 now okay pause for
a moment because
I mean I want to take with the queen of
course and not to mess up my Pawn
structure but I'm I am thinking about
this dark sweared Bishop for just a
moment and I wanted to ask the question
can I
be greedy you know and
like if you were to play the move Knight
before that's unpleasant and then you
put your knight on A2
your Grandmaster title like it might be
in Jeopardy once again E7 so
yes exactly after C6 you have to play 97
and that's a nice piece of
97. and that was where I thought okay
we're more or less uh got to an equal
position yeah
and once again just uh for those who are
joining us late our standings uh are we
looking at firusha and Rapport they are
yeah not not great right now Richard's
in the fifth place for Asia in the
seventh place but it's always time to
come back and an important game for both
of them as they try to improve their
positioning in the tournament and Miro
over to you as uh I see you've got
neposite Innova yep big news
uh remember we were talking this
position yes and years right so some
attack on black skin we as human players
were scared computer was not and queen
C7 was the right move however G6
Fearless needed to be played F5 is more
of a once again very human reaction I'm
sacrificing the pawn just not please do
not Checkmate me right it takes Knight
takes it turns out nepoplate Bishop B1
which is good enough turns out Knight H4
immediately was even stronger because
yeah because Knight G6 threat and
seemingly the best move is just to go
King G6 after which you capture the pawn
with a check right after Bishop B1
still like blackhead to play E5 which he
didn't
Knight to D5 Knight to C4 move 19
computer gives plus one evaluation in
White's favor now suddenly white pieces
start to find their places like Knight
Kills 25 right yeah Bishop ready to jump
with the temple like Bishop G5 will be
threatening Bishop 6 in some positions
right so I'm just wondering Bishop B5
right it's a pin and so on but Knight
ce5 is good enough if you capture what
happens it's a church King goes it's
another check King Rook girls and then
Knight G2 E5 okay maybe not not such an
obvious not such an obvious line I
suspect Queen C1 runs into Bishop H7 and
then the queen will be captured so a bit
of you know like tactical blows exchange
but works in White's favor in every
possible line
lovely very lovely right so nepo is in
his campaign for three out of three
today and he he's got the type of
position that he could have only dreamed
of against the lower rate lower rated uh
Constantine I want to say a game that we
haven't uh looked at our apologies to
the two players uh googes and sarich
um
it was also an lapping but this one was
with G3 I don't even know how
what what the name is it's in a Lapin
with G3
it's I think it's called delayed jalapen
or something I'm not sure
I like I like the delay though that's
that's good and it was just one of those
Pawn sacrifices that I really like from
White uh point of view you get these
Catalan Bishops right with this bishop
on G2 you're a pawn down sure if you had
a Pawn on C2 I think the game would be
greatly in White's favor after moves
like Bishop to well move your queen uh I
don't know F6 or G5 uh I'm gonna win the
pawn back and I like these positions
where I get the split pawns so I like
gookash's position I think he has an
advantage alireza
uh
after Knight D4 no trades uh just simply
Queen G3 by the way that comes with a
tempo right Bishop takes H6 uh Richie do
something pay attention King H7 King H7
now there is one difference right now if
I take if you take with the queen then I
can Bishop D4 yeah I'll just uh but can
I still play C6 your idea
no I wanted to trade Queen sorry
now instead of Queen takes the six yes
well I can still play C6 right oh
can you maybe not maybe because there's
E5
right oops
no that's Pawn that's two pawns that's
that's going to be too much so Queen G3
Miro right has some very Salient
questions you know all your analysis
makes sense if you're not a computer
yeah but no no you're absolutely right
yes I mean when I've seen this queen G3
uh before paying attention to the
evaluation my first thought is oh okay
King is in danger let's do something of
course you don't have to worry about the
king if you are a computer so dc5
according to the machine black is
already better
because Bishop H6 F6 not impressed I
understand it looks scary but black has
a very strong threat of 66 which doesn't
win the material but pushes white
species I mean trades the Bishops right
right and pushes all the white pieces
like a bad bad position so after dc5
black is already better if he if it will
be played and by the fact that Richard
is posing here and not playing King H7
or King h8 immediately I suspect he
might find this one
and in fact uh the the nice part about
it is that
he played C6 yes played C6 immediately
which also works because now if Bishop
takes you play F6 because King H7 D
takes C takes D6 is so good for white
you don't uh you you you find that the
alternative of taking on C5 as well as
seasick sorry Miro so he's late yes and
now with Bishop H6 he's gonna go F6
uh you don't want to go to b40c3 so you
have to end these complications Bishop
captures yeah Bishop captures with the
check you take with the Knight
C takes B6 for a brief moment
yeah you were born up and then C5 and
just look at this structure so B6 Pawn
is going to be lost sooner or later
right and why doesn't really have a lot
of counter play I would argue yeah you
can play a four machine says but Black's
not impressed he goes Rook A6 by the way
Bishop H6 F6 on the board speaking yep
on a board yep well slightly better for
black maybe with potential to be not so
slightly better yeah at the positional
Advantage is long term yeah because
Knight versus Bishop in the closed
position like that the thing is I think
we're trained as players uh when we see
our opponent making a threat so our
immediate reaction is oh you're going to
threaten me well I'll stop you I will
put up my fence and I will uh so we see
the threat of Bishop H6 we don't
hesitate we play King H7 King h8 but
oftentimes we forget to stop ourselves
and say well how severe is it if I allow
you to make that move Bishop takes H6
and you'll be threatening Checkmate oh I
can resign I can Panic or I can
recognize that wait a minute after I
play the move F6 guarding the threat
it's not so severe and that position
that Miro was pointing out Knight B6
Bishop takes B6 you've got to trade on
E6 no choice Knight takes you have to
capture now we're a pawn down
but once we see the move C5 and we say
well there's no thread of checkmate at
all we've got that beautifully protected
and as soon as we play Rook here Rook
takes for like yeah very nice position
who who's better and why and we have it
that's a very good example of when you
see a good good move look for a better
one because King H7 was a good move but
it was Richard took his time and found a
better one he did indeed and we think
that uh well uh if I've even necessary
why not immediately look Asics I suppose
Rook A6 Bishop E3 and then I'll play C5
because the bishop is not going to force
Checkmate on its own uh Accord but we'll
have this on the board okay six was
played Rook a six
immediately so for ferozan after C5
try to open kingside up a little bit
maybe F4 I think he should
because frankly if we don't I see from
from black spots yeah I'll put the Rook
on B3 I'll post The Rook on B3 I'll play
Queen B5 and I'll be
um putting some serious pressure on both
the D3 and B2 bonds
um alireza for a moment there was really
enjoying life he was he had just
defeated Magnus Carlson for those of you
joining us late uh you missed a you know
a Dandy and it looked like he was
cruising there for just a moment the man
when he played Queen G3 but Richie is
turning the tables a bit I like it
and Miro tell us about uh Magnus who a
little update on magnus's game yeah and
unlike many of us as we as we were
speaking yesterday you have this
advantage of better pieces placement in
a symmetrical position and you end up
giving disadvantage away unless you're
Magnus Carlsen okay so in few more moves
he managed to capitalize on this one
Knight to B5 attacking the queen queen
B6 and then if you're a computer you
don't even capture the pawn you take
over here on C6 and Gill Knight D6 and
claim that this is even better than what
happened in the game but
um yeah we are humans after all night
takes A7 that's what Magnus did it wins
the pawn Knight takes A7 a little funny
tactic Knight takes here Knight takes on
CA black has to capture and white uh
wins back the night he's a pawn up black
in order to not resign immediately so
not to not to stop here being a pawn
down has to go through K8 and this might
be a little problematic to win because
Queens are traded and it's one double
pawn and F6 in this type of end game
might not be such a bad move it might be
useful absolutely right it still favors
computer still favors white but I would
say which is not without the chance yeah
you had me at a pawn up there I was
getting all expectations
let's do it uh nepo has just uh landed
quite the move a visual after Knight C4
Bishop B a bishop
E8 sorry Knight
H5 uh
eyeballing the F4 Square nepo said go
for it
G4 wow uh really the G4 is a very
aggressive move but it's also weakening
move yes yeah if it was correct well I
mean the idea of course is oops don't
allow a Checkmate and if you have to go
back well uh yeah maybe it's not the
greatest but wait a minute you know
there are ideas of Knight to G5 as well
as knights in between moves okay in the
game
Bishop D6 okay
E5
Bishop E5 95 yes 1965 and here I thought
he had maybe Queen B6 which he didn't
play oh
oh that would have been a varossing a
surprise
because you can just play a rookie too
you attack I defend that kind of thing
because I still don't have Knight F4
well you you were telling me about those
little in-between movies
for a good move what do you think
um
I don't like the move G4 uh exposing my
king is something I very very reluctant
to do right but the simple logic that
the position is already good right right
why do I need it yeah why would I give
chances uh you guessed correctly that
Knight F6 was bad because interestingly
G5 and G6 just like that just go forward
and splat and yeah and this one wins he
found the first line of the good
variation for black lupulasco that is
rookie one and then the second move I
don't think it's easy he had to go
Bishop before and it is a really hard
move to play wow so the fact is The Rook
is kind of overloaded protecting the
Knight and the discipline C1 yeah and
the Nikon H5 is hanging
but the moment why it captures the night
he no longer has a threat on the H file
and this is something that in my very
hard to realize yeah so the Knight is
hanging but it's not it's kind of
hanging enough right so and Bishop B4
Believe It or Not computer has it Rook
F1 Bishop D6 rookie one and let's make
it through four and let's make a draw so
apparently I'm not claiming that there
is no way for white to continue but at
least according to computer that was the
big chance for loophole so G4 was a
mistake was a mistake yeah like looks
like any sane move keeps the advantage
Bishop to Bishop D3 and G4 even though
of course logical but a bit impatient
but looks like in the game it worked out
for nepo because now I see his Pawn is
all the way on G6 exactly so after
bishop and also let's take a notice this
time he has 17 minutes against lupus
cost 53 seconds 53 seconds yes yikes
Bishop takes E5 Knight takes E5 Knight
drops back and this is precisely what
the doctor ordered for nepo G5 Knight H5
G6 give me that night the Knight had to
drop back and now nepo can just grab a
second Pawn
oh pardon me is that a First Pawn
I'm not sure that's the first one yeah
sorry uh it grabbed the pawn on H7 and
uh well he's got beautiful attack
Queen is E6 Bishop is coming to play and
even the bishop pardon me if I can go
Bishop to G6 and Bishop takes and Knight
G6 will be Checkmate and the 53 seconds
too that doesn't help so uh Constantine
uh he's being uh he's being targeted uh
Europe was thinking about because
obviously I mean seeing what computer
suggests it's very funny yeah uh there
is Bishop G5 in this position which is
logical kind of developing the bishop
but there is also a sneaky move a283
a283 point being that's very likely E6
is going to drop and Bishop A2 Is What
It Wants at some point ghost A3 and
Bishop A2 which is which is funny oh boy
and it's much better it's much better
for white of course but but for me if
I'm in Napa of shoes and I've just
gotten on G4 G5 G6
and you know Wild Horses couldn't stop
me from playing G6 takes H7 I mean you
know like I'm Unleashed I might as well
make it all the way up the board might
not be looking at eighth revision yeah
and the A3 would not be on my uh radar
at all what's interesting if you take on
H7 with dependent after Knight D7 black
is back in the game black is back he's
still fighting because yeah like the
pieces are the piece provides are still
not that uh let's say not that well
coordinated so and you're probably
killing your attack on the H file the
pawn on H7 is actually helping black
it's one of those cases yes exactly
and again I was so proud of myself when
I I came to understand that a white Pawn
on H7 could be interfering with the
attack your your opponent uh Pawn is
acting as a shield uh let's go around
the horn quickly uh because I'm sure the
games have been heating up let's go to
the game between Fabi and in Duda
because it seems to mean like Bobby has
made quite a progress the minority
attack has
missed the mark completely there's no B5
at all and it seems to me that Duda is
kind of rearranging his pieces but not
necessarily achieving anything in the
whole process
yeah that's the way I feel it looks
solid for weight it's probably equal
yeah I think that's a fair assessment uh
has Magnus pardon me where are you
Magnus Port four yep have you Magnus
achieved well you've you've got the
extra Pawn but you've got the ending
that Mira was talking about where the
pawn on F6 is actually useful in the
middle games that we were seeing the
pawn was not that great
but uh
the extra response
yeah he's always converting drojan games
he's a beast at grinding away uh Rook D7
and King F7 I was about to save this you
went King f8 right away an indication
that after King E2 he might want to play
rookie seven no
excuse me Rook to C7 King to D3 and now
King F7 somehow I feel like maybe vishi
lost a Tempo in that but he is looking
for 96. I would try to
stop
my opponent 94 looks very good yeah it's
a certainly
I like G4 for white G4 just gaining some
space yeah I'm playing on all three
sides
uh how how do you like B5 and maybe B4
B5 96 B4
just gaining a little bit more space
over there
with 94
could consider those options yeah and I
liked also
you know it's funny I I like gaining
space with G4 I like painting space with
B5 okay Magnus is doing his thing is
nepo doing his thing guess what nepo
also thought
it didn't take better G6 takes H7
they're my impatience of wanting to
capture on H7 got the better I mean
Bishop to D2 very natural move by the
way H6
and
50 seconds from age six so badly with
every fighter of your being right
um it's probably nothing though because
queen queen comes to G7 ready wouldn't
you want to take out E6 as well though
uh yeah I guess that point is just
hanging
for sure right I mean Knight D7 is
potentially on uh Black's agenda and
queen takes E6 means that D5 is hanging
so you're not you're not moving
if you will
yeah Queen E6 looks good uh mural uh
jump in on this one uh
I'm a pond Grabber dude right you are I
want to take this phone however once
again the engine really wants this
bishop 182 This Time by going A4 for
whatever reason or just to play Bishop
D3 yeah and develop the pieces and so on
well that's Rook C1 too so let's check
out what yeah Queen E6 is an advantage
to have a bishop D7 and Knight F7 Jack
Knight F7
um what am I blundering I'm afraid it's
it doesn't want to play Knight hook
seven you see it won't allow you Rook F7
yes and the queen is getting no no
Knight G4 come on Queen H2 Queen H2 ig4
that's what the machine says I had no
idea to be honest you cannot protect H2
in a sufficient way right because F4 and
there will be a check and so on so
apparently the moral of the story is
that we need to develop the queen side
first wow that's why and he did Play
Bishop D3
which is a good move yeah nice uh let's
just jump to uh farusha versus Richie
report for a moment because that game
also kind of got away from us uh F4 was
played by the way F5 Knight D4 and look
at this Richie yeah
big time that is a very handsome Pawn
very healthy pawn and I don't see how
white can Rook E3 and look at that you
know everything's gone
this looks outstanding for Richie uh
farusia big trouble on this one Miro uh
right you are right you are it's it's
extra pawn and really positioned well
it's up to
-3 plus three in Black's favor yeah and
then and looking at the lines I can
hardly spot anything where white gets to
play against Black's King
so right if if the game will continue
like I take on D5 you know and we'll try
to protect my weak pawns no it's not
good not a pleasant uh situation when
did he somewhere around this moment I
guess Knight D4 Bishop E3 was still fine
Bishop D4 now maybe he underestimated
the whole thing yeah it looks just a bad
position oh I think it allowing rookie 2
rookie 3 was much worse for white I
didn't have to play Rook F1 yeah he had
to push the age but still it doesn't
change the relation dramatically black
is still better exactly uh by the way
there was a nitrate in magnus's game
after Knight to D4 Knight C6 there was a
trade so we're in this Rook ending where
again we're nursing this extra half a
bond because it's a doubled Pawn well I
think
it's much better because now if Rook has
to move right we can't go in the pawn
ending down the pawn
can we uh
uh but if Rook moves I have Rook D7 well
exactly Rook Rook B6 or Rook C6 Rook to
D7
rugby six but this move Rook D7 looks
dreadful for a moment there is that King
and pawning game completely winning
wasn't completely winning right marrow
yes to me well you know I'm afraid we
need yeah we need more computer power on
this but it claims to be winning okay I
can well believe it but what we do have
by the way is Magnus magic once again
because this Rook ending looks
absolutely Dreadful yeah this one's this
one's really really bad uh after the
move uh King C4 I'm threatening B5
winning on the spot so Rook Beast Rook
C6 check was a force situation
my king is too close to the B Pawn
exactly that's why it should be winning
exactly I'm thinking that the Rook will
um
rearrange itself there is very annoying
move now Rook to D2 I want to go King
Ace 4 and B5 and D5 played then back to
D5 with exactly Rook to D2 to protect to
defend against C2 and what you were
saying the king is just too close to the
B6 spawn a king A4 and Magnolia that's a
that's the type of move that moved Rook
D2 that Magnus is just so
you know
great at finding another move that I
found attractive was Rook to C3 with the
idea of putting the pawn on B5 and Rook
C6 I think it's choices uh what else is
happening is also in his game
it was equal for a long time but now it
looks like
yeah this one it's about to win material
when we left it we left it just here and
I was uh installing the virtues of uh
splitting the opponent's pawn and he
took the pawn on C5 he's up two pawns
now and uh
whoa whoa whoa whoa uh he said oh sorry
The Rook on E8 is hanging okay good
morning St Louis uh I was about to
blunder the bishop Queen takes E4 but I
was blundering The Rook so first of all
we've got to move the Rook so Rook B8
Pro all right let's have a look and then
I have a Tempo against the queen right
you can play Queen C6 also
[Laughter]
nice unnecessary in red okay style
points you're getting the style points
there Nasi today nice so Rook B8 Queen
C6 as well as rookie one two pawns
should be winning is time a factor by
the way
they're both under three minutes
by the way Ivan sarage uh for he's had
some really excellent positions and in
day one he could have potentially won at
a certain moment just a key moment uh
against uh Magnus he did have a winning
moment I want to put it like that
uh do we have Rook B8 on the board no
not yet but we have updates in knuckles
game sure he has managed to win the E6
Pawn
and keep the extra Health upon alive all
right so we left it at Bishop D3 Knight
G8
and he's about to win his third game in
a row
and that means six points because the
double points that you get for winning a
rapid game brings him like that's uh
hitting the trampoline you know and he
brings them right back into a tournament
that he was doing poorly in Marrow I
mean Jan was crying at breakfast with
Anastasia how do I win one game in a row
well
won the first one now who can stop him
exactly uh
and uh well I see that you're putting
Queen A3 on the board is that necessary
no that that wasn't clever yeah make
sure there is a check yeah uh just a
little update if you allow me please
report because well Richie
he he's still better but over here after
H oops
ah come on they started to play
immediately right when I got in this
position after age five it seems that
better was Queen E5 and then having some
Rook G3 ideas he went with Queen D6 Rook
F4 Queen A3 so he said the fruit F4
white could have played H6 and turns out
it's not that obvious
three yeah and Rook G3 Queen H4 and
somehow computer finds some idea it's
less than a pawn for black in this line
uh things seem to be heating up uh Queen
takes A3 and H6 are H6 yeah so you have
to create something against the king or
resign only two options right eight Pawn
too many extra pawns right computer's
not impressed it actually preserves his
extra Pawn with C5 and rookie one is the
blunder and now it's equal what this is
how it works yeah so now it takes green
takes go to H2 right and it says it's
equal and by the way the only way to
make it equal is to go back to E7 and
then go to D7 or D6 check and still yeah
well perhaps now it's this content plays
enough wow so rookie one Slips Away the
advantage and what you what he should
have done was just replace C6 C5 defend
upon TV C5 was good Rook F7 was good so
he controls the E file there is uh well
no need to exchange the E3 Rook for F1
Rook which he has done by the way Queen
takes E1 King H2 King H2 is on the board
Queen E7 and Richie kind of play Queen
E7 happily not realizing that perhaps
Rook E4 is give his rookie four there is
also Rook D4 at some point computer was
saying so that means uh simply the
position changed it's not a sudden
chance anymore you you can take here and
as well it's only minus 0.1 instead of
-3 which was like few moves ago wow
stunning
um again I want to just go around the
horn quickly because I think we're
getting it in time trouble we do have
the game of Vichy and Magnus and let's
see what happened when we left it right
on cue Rook D2 King A4 King's going
hunting yes uh Pond hunting King B5
H4 and we're expecting to take the pawn
right King B6 Rook before King C5
correct and we're just ready to play B4
and after Rook B3
and he's done it and for Vichy I mean
this is just
I mean I can't imagine how
painful this is because he's played a
great event he just had drawn with the
black pieces
and if he had gotten past this test I
mean you know the goal of winning the
event is you know in reach and now
he's he's going to go down to his first
defeat and this is just so painful
because he's had a great tournament so
far just great all right started with a
draw then won three games in a row yep
then another draw against Bobby with the
black pieces and it wasn't the opening
maybe he was slightly worse out of the
opening it's just some remarkable play
by Magnus though in the end of this
magic and uh yeah I think now it's just
completely winning it's like it's
passively defending there's no counter
play on the king side exactly it's just
a matter of time and The Rook will if
the Rook goes back to B8 The Rook will
come to B2 and even at the cost of the
f-pawn you're picking up the rook and
that's that's uh
that's the game that's the game
um looks like we're going to have a lot
of decisive games in the last round well
no question about it and that really
impacts the tournament dramatically
because of uh Fabi has won a pawn if
I've got this right just a second
what
I'm trying to count them
not yet not yet he hasn't went upon yet
but wait a minute he's about to I have a
couple visuals for you yes please uh
yeah so that was a position off to move
20 if you look compare okay on your
analysis board compare position of the
move 20 yeah and position enough to move
uh 36. and if you can tell any
difference in Pawn structure yeah well
why the whole thing has changed there
was a lot of maneuvering and it ended up
with black playing A5 not white playing
B5 but black playing A5 exactly it looks
like Magnus won his game Magnus is the
first to uh win and uh
I have to say you know Magnus after
those back-to-back losses
to win against Vichy the tournament on
demand because let's face it if he
doesn't win this game and stop vishy
he's got no chances I mean vishy Vichy
will Cruise so our congratulations to to
Magnuson and that will be that would be
so sore
none uh let's go to napo's uh game uh
very quickly
where I think he's put in the final
touches I like that he actually used his
time went down from 17 minutes to three
minutes now that he's winning 50 seconds
yeah he's taking his time to convert
just to not let lupusco Escape yeah
it's an interesting like Fortress that
black has on the king side of course
white has an extra Pawn it's a winning
but how do we break through yeah I was
thinking that you know you just want to
play H3 so you make sure that this is
nope and then you go you know rookie
eights black right I don't know exactly
how you're supposed to go rookie eights
black but that's that's H3 yeah okay you
just tidy things up a little bit there
yeah maybe Queenie five Queen E7 is
Queen exchange should be great right
right
Queen E5 Queen E7 Queen E7 as well as
Queen C5 yeah but that move h2h3 so we
yeah Queen E5 or is
hesitating there was something there
that uh the last seconds
check King G1
and what you were saying Queen E7 is
once that makes an appearance we're
gonna take it and go rookie eight right
oops uh Miro uh looks like uh nepo is
going to go three out of three
uh yes right you are yes that's
completely winning after this last move
Queen E6 is the easiest
Queen E6 and you were right about this
idea that eventually you want something
on E8 right also Queen E4 maybe just to
force the queen exchange yes Queenie for
also very very nice Winnie voice puts
the Final Touch yes
Queen F5 he plays neither not the
mistake
not a mistake
he is reaching for his rookie wants to
go rookie eight
Rook E8 that's not miss any Knight F3
moves take it
wait we're on G5 rookie Knight F3 check
and take on F3
Knight F3
Queen G6 oh Jack
but then after Knight F3 yes no longer
winning what oh plus one only plus 0.9
if black finds Knight F3 and what do you
do even no he didn't he went Queen C1
and it slides out that's that's a lucky
break for an apple right now no I mean
that's shocking why is a king
nappa's playing very very quickly here
he he's got three minutes well he's
excited too okay here you can block with
the queen on e4 what yes that's
beautiful Queenie for you you're safe to
play Queen E4 uh F3 not bad not bad
either
okay he's going to win yes he's going to
win what about uh Fabio he just won and
he did win we were there for that he
just I heard I saw him say Knight of
three
because he noticed oh
and jumping uh to the game of Fabi
versus Duda uh fabi's won a couple of
Pawns here is that one Pawn but he has
two connected pastors now yeah but is
this King a little bit uh vulnerable
after G4 well I like why it's essential
pawns as well
exactly uh how do we get to the king
well for Duda by the way he he he can't
wait
I mean he's got to get his counter play
in virtually immediately he plays Knight
E4
night before but Rook d8 first I have to
play Rook D1 okay D7
eight seconds
four three
I mean uh I saw Arena crash in the
Karen's cup playing with one second on
her clock no problem
makes her move after Rook to e to D7 am
I just losing the different Pawn
that was my question I was thinking that
uh the move E5 is a surprise for me
uh but Rook to D7
hello Miro jump in right I mean if you
want to know what computer things yeah
you better don't because it's it's
overwhelming for yeah Queen C4 wasn't
the best and then white could have
fought his way back to the game E5 is a
bit of a mistake right a rook d8 Rook D1
now you can play rookie to D7 or just go
away for black is well minus two minus
two and a half winning no no attack
there is no direct win there there's no
like you know win immediately which was
available instead of Queen C4
12 seconds against minute and 15. okay
a few routers game it looked like he was
saving the Rook ending but now
firoza has lost completely
oh yeah no that's that Rook is it was a
moment where he took the pawn instead of
going for the a pawn that was very
strange move 42.
he
if we can go to move 42. move 42 so
instead of uh Rook take C6 wait a second
and it's back to drive okay seven and
take the A4 Pawn
so why take C6 when you can take A4
exactly and what is going on here how is
this a drawing
uh
uh I'm just going to catch up to the
current position oh this is
kind of stuck yeah there's The Rook
behind the pond now he put the Rook on
the side of the pond that was
was that clever so what was the mistake
uh if you if you check the moment when
he played A2 which is attempting move
rookie five was winning that's bad
that's the only moment wow
this is an unusual safe to say the least
oh my goodness I mean he was playing
these very natural looking moves uh
picking up the pawn on D3 playing A2
and I mean still so now he's trying to
get the king to the queen side
of course it takes a long time so I
should just maybe push the pawn G5 yeah
G5 is the only move to save the game now
right
right if I move the king of course King
D5 looks yeah it's not that you've got
many moves right yeah
by the way just to boldly State the
obvious we have two results and both
games have been decisive so three games
remaining we've got G6 on the board
expecting and the other two games are
also decisive decisive kokesh is winning
and Fabiano is winning
exactly and again for those of you
joining us late nepo is made a run for
the Roses as he's won the Triple Crown
for today three games in a row
picking up six points six crucial points
Fabi
um two seconds with two seconds
we're getting about his clock
oh that was a great move by faruga it's
because such an interesting end game you
just want to sit and calculate exactly
but three seconds two seconds
look back to A1
yes yes we're back to A1 threatens the
D4 we're gonna see the repetition
wow what a save by firosha
that was remarkable
truly
that we are threatening G7 here
everything has to be done
three seconds keep trying D3
7 Rook G2 King D3 and yeah yeah that's
going to be a draw we can turn our
attention to the game of Fabi for a
moment because this game is deciding uh
second place and probably he's winning
and he just resigned as we as we were
joining the game uh Fabi just uh over
time
yes Libra
and kukesh looks like his he has three
extra pawns we have opposite color
Bishop end games but rook's still on the
board
and finally we do have a draw between
Richie and farrugia but the three extra
pawns you you had me at one extra upon
the three extra pawns kukesh how is he
doing how did he do that how do how do
you do that
we were not following that game so I'm
not sure yet but okay so gookesh will
just play Bishop E2 uh with his three
extra pawns he'll start to play H5 and
just uh push a baby H5 and G4
and
I was about to say you gained a tempo
you want to keep King's going to go to
you like to keep the pawn on F2 so and
he resigns and kukesh wins two in a row
Bravo and one game remaining no I think
no that's nothing remains yes sir no
once again four decisive no wait a
minute yes four decisive games
well round sorry day one was full of
fireworks
well bring it on continues yeah it was
about to say happy happy Fourth of July
and the fireworks continues as uh well
the leaderboard got all scrambled there
as Vichy our leader lost but so did our
runner-up Duda and Fabi uh did Fabi
catch Ananda
I think he caught enough that he passed
wow okay we'll get you the standings uh
shortly but a very eventful
yeah who would have guessed Nepal
winning three games in a row Magnus
losing the first two right and coming
back and beating the leader of the
tournament completely unpredictable
again I mean for me you know I really
feel that I think chess players in
general really feel the loss the pain of
the loss greater than the joy of the
Victory and it's sort of like for Vichy
you know that's lost to Magnus really
really really hurts because he was just
so so close to passing uh this huge test
he had black with Fabby the game before
very very comfortable draw it looked
like he did very well out of the opening
and Magnus had well a little bit of a
nibble but nothing serious but it was
Knight takes A7 Miro uh that uh that
really rocked vichy's world right yeah
and then perhaps close to perfect how
technique and the position I have on the
board it's not about the position but
the player who we I'm afraid do not
mention enough go cash yeah so two wins
today and not only that if you check on
accuracy or quality of his play he's
amazing yes tell us about the accuracy
how accurate was it well
can't do so without the computer in this
particular one right but yeah there were
some moments when it looked like he was
very close to dropping the advantage he
would pick it up again and yeah like
winning even this position right
opposite colored Bishops but black has
you know some counter play and so on now
he managed and when I'm talking accuracy
I mean his game against Rapport was just
amazing with seconds on the clock
remembering first round of today yeah
interesting and let's uh jump uh to
Zagreb and check in with our colleagues
thanks yes uh Jan first of all uh
welcome back to our show three victories
in a row yesterday you told Anastasia
you asked her how do you win one game in
a row now you won three
yeah I had like uh
you know
I was really curious at some point like
it was uh like rapid chess I guess was
my arguably strongest discipline yeah
like so I played uh really nice but okay
now my reaching print low and okay I'm
playing everyone was so shiny uh so it
turns out maybe that I should also
calculate some lines here not to play
like Blitz
uh so just it's Blitz with like 25
minutes uh it's good you know
you have some drawback here of getting a
bad position too early but this was
always your style right yeah something
wasn't working what was it no I can't
say it was my style so I was calculating
a lot all the time but okay now I became
like old and uh yeah lazy yeah I'm just
trying to play with hands only yeah
without like any
any calculations so yeah that's
something I try to adjust today and yeah
it worked
worked nicely but uh overall I think uh
games or not so not so great well let's
talk about this game uh against yourself
and Richie because I was definitely
impressed with your opening knowledge
like you were blitzing out your moves
and yeah and go to a bad position
yes well actually I think I was the one
who introduced this line more or less uh
in some online online repute I guess it
was like during covet or something
uh so I knew I think it's about this
line but the age remove maybe I went for
this uh
plan which is too ambitious yeah like uh
if white plays like Queen D2 Queen F4
Queen H4 which which is another plan for
it here then okay then you can go for uh
97 b86
but here are the way is way more natural
yeah like okay another night but
whatever yeah uh but this bishop
frequency 2 is more natural and um I
think I'm not in time with this Knight
C6 play but when I analyze the position
it suddenly had a very strong move at
some point
here at what I'm doing quite nice and I
think perhaps yeah here I should have
taken only five perhaps uh but I wasn't
sure like after the f694 I wasn't sure
about this position so id4 Knight E4 of
course yeah uh so maybe I played a D5
take a pawn maybe something else okay
this is very very
very unclear so
I mean surely I decided to start with
like F6 so after 9g4 I take one F5 but
here was some some genius move Bishop G4
which is like hard to
I mean hard to explain why is the move
why this move is so strong but yeah just
to show something like you here
we start with like Chase Jake's Bishop
G4 here I have like a five Jake's
perhaps Jake's heroines well D5 for
Bishop D7 is uh should be quite playable
yeah yeah but uh Bishop G4 immediately
is something I you know foreign
maybe in a classical game but definitely
not in a rapid no I mean okay just this
move makes not so much sense to me but
yeah it's very strong yeah but here uh
yeah here suddenly I felt like
I had sort of an upper hand with my
place so easy but after you have to see
free I think he's nearly lost yeah yeah
perhaps with some precise play he could
like hold on but yeah this position
overall is uh
I mean uh yeah he tried to sacrifice an
exchange here but I guess yeah this was
yeah once again I was like too late to
calculate so he just chopped on D5 and
this is pretty it's pretty much
technical but I'm not sure if it's
winning but it looks like very nice
chances still three out of three a
perfect day for you you're I think in a
co-leading position right now
um how do you feel confidence wise and
how important is confidence for you and
for your type of play
uh you know it's better to be confident
or not
I guess it's uh more or less Works to
everyone in the same way uh yeah but uh
I'm more or less
you know I think it's it would be
difficult to play worse than yesterday
frankly
just I think I was lost at some point in
all three games yeah and uh
yeah and also I need some very nice
tactics against bookish I guess
when he played the queen before it was
like a queen C4 there was like Bishop B5
almost winning uh yeah so I didn't see
like anything so today I think like I
played a little bit better so at least I
made some reasonable
uh moves yeah some nice decisions but uh
yeah it's yet
I mean it's unclear so it's one day was
a bit one day it was good yeah so let's
see what happens tomorrow yeah always
great to have you back at your best uh
go get some rest and we'll see you
tomorrow thank you guys back to you
thank you nepo and here are the
standings after two incredibly eventful
days wow things have changed a lot in
the last two rounds they certainly have
so we have three co-leaders now Fabiano
caruana Yani promise all sitting on
eight points being chased being chased
uh by Duda which is not surprising by
the kukesh who just won two games in a
row and it's fighting to join the
leaders absolutely with Magnus Carlson
and Richie Rapport behind them and we've
got to get in some thank yous first of
all to the foundations in Croatia the
super United as well as the full of life
and here I mean really big shout out to
the St Louis chess club and Scholastic
Center for everything that they do for
us and boy do they take good care of us
when we're in St Louis so thank you
everybody and again in Croatia the fall
of Life Foundation as well as the super
United thank you for that and Miro uh I
could you tell me about that Knight F3
moment that Constantine had because I
thought after rookie eight it was going
to be a handshake right there
you know honestly I'm not sure if nepo
is aware of it
because yet he mentioned something about
gay one but he didn't tell about this
one so once again for those who might be
joining us right now that's a game
between nipom Nishi and lupulasco nepo
is winning for like the last 20 moves
right and he goes for a decisive blow
which is rookie a right and you've seen
this bar dropped because of Knight F3
check and then I think you just
calculate okay I chopped the Knight he
cannot take the queen because it's a
Checkmate right and there is a little
problem that if you take on F3 he
captures on G6 with a check
and this one computer has us better for
white because King goes somewhere it
takes Stakes apps takes there but no
it's not really bad it's almost a draw
right so after Knight F3 and I've tried
to play the other line which is King F1
and then it's a check King to G2 and you
win the queen and once again you win the
queen but can you cannot really take it
because there is a Checkmate still so
you give this check and white girls F4
and black has to find that this is
important black has to find Queen D6 and
for whatever reason this saves because
now takes Queen takes
uh Queen has to go
Knight G6 Queen G6 and the only move so
once again we are saying that this like
Knight F3 would have made the draw in
case you would find next five six
strictly only moves Queen E7 is the only
move because now the king is getting
into Perpetual check
and that's that's it yeah so it was a
sudden chance but it was a tough one wow
uh yeah Knight F3 didn't force a draw
just wanted to say let's go back to
zagrev and uh Christian as he's with a
special guest
first of all welcome to the show but uh
more importantly welcome to the
grandchester this is your first
participation at the grandchester how
are you feeling and how important is
this tournament for you
I'm feeling very nice to be here this is
my grandchester debut and of course I've
been following
pretty much all the grandchester events
and
yeah it's quite important to me I hope
to do well and
put on a good performance you're
definitely doing uh just that it was a
slow first day for you obviously the
first game against Magnus that's always
uh difficult but you picked up the pace
in day two and you finished with two
important victories talk to us about
that about the change of mindset from
yesterday to today that helped you
yes today I would say it's a decent
start I mean losing against Magnus is
not something that should never happen
of course yeah after that I I played to
interesting games which I ended in a
draw I was feeling pretty good and
yeah today against rap why I might have
had some chances and then in the end he
had this uh
can we let's see if we can put that game
that was round four if I'm not mistaken
yes so in the end
I think I was better at some point but
you were with the white pieces
just to give some background the story
oh yeah this crazy game yeah and he
actually had a win I think at some point
towards the end and the window is quite
nice I missed Rook F3 and then
yeah yeah he had to go like talking F1
yes Bishop H3 but he has to go Rook F2
first king even Rook back now he's no
longer hanging yeah and he can play
Space Three you know he has uh some
checks yeah
one
was it this I believe ah sorry there is
a bishop to H3 right yeah
exactly yeah and there's no Rook hanging
on it yeah
this was uh yeah this was a Miss win for
him did you spot it during the game no I
didn't support him but I I kind of felt
that there should be something because
the two rocks and marocon be forage
felt like there should be something but
I didn't say but okay it was just a Time
scramble so that was fine and
then you get energy from this time
scrambles because you know you you get
the adrenaline running and everything
that comes with it
yeah I try not to go to time scrambles
because it's a bit too crazy for me but
yeah sometimes I land up there and
let's talk about the last game also
because uh I feel that one was quite
smooth and really enjoyed your
conversion talk to us about this game
actually I just missed Knight A5 which
which is just uh one blunder right
because B3 Queen F6 and
yeah
oh sorry I think he has to take ed5
first
and then CD queen of six
Knight C3 and uh
some somewhat still survivable actually
white is just fine okay
okay I saw like
because
chatter about this ago
and this turns into a mess
you change down but you have great
compensation I thought I've learned okay
so that's why I didn't play B3 but
okay with Knight C3 I just like cut me
that I made a mistake
like us trying to equalize
and uh
yeah here I saw a nice trick
so Rook D1 and yeah here I spotted he
has to go Queen C8 after which Bishop G4
yeah after which I probably have to do
this
I mean and the end game is not pleasant
but it should be holdable yeah
maybe lose the B3 phone off Thursday
yeah but C4 I thought before but but
yeah it's not pleasant yes
it's like limited material you're close
to yeah maybe pulling a draw
so you win Queen F6 and I spotted this
nice trick with Queen E3 the point being
shaved for I have my T4 oh that's very
nice so here uh I already equalizer and
I'm starting to get ambitious yeah and
queen Affair was just a bad moment
but
uh yeah Knight D5 was the point
but maybe he can go okay and then I saw
um
yes
very nice but he seems to have made some
mistakes along the way perhaps already
this Knight C4
he already he gave up a phone and night
safer was already equipped yeah and now
it just became a matter of conversion
yeah my conventional conversion was not
smooth but I think it was enough forever
good enough
good enough good cash congratulations uh
you're already used to playing against
all these uh great players at such a
young age congratulations go get some
rest and we'll see you tomorrow yeah
thank you Christian thank you good cash
as we have a very tumultuous round six
tell us about our standings message we
have
we have omniscient Vision with eight
points as we say all to play for right
and just one point behind the young
Christoph Duda in kukesh and it's
very hard to believe that Magnus is not
in the first half of the standings but
we know he can pull off anything so
he'll be trying to win all three games
tomorrow definitely and Miro I kind of
sum up again another uh topsy-turvy day
uh absolutely and it kind of proves that
doesn't matter how how good or how bad
you did on day one there is always a
room to turn it upside down right we can
see Jan pulling up three out of three
and at the same time Magnus struggling
in even after beating visionand in the
principal game he is still only on 50 so
the only thing I want to remind that the
tournament does not end tomorrow right
there will be Blitz as well it's a long
distance to cover and practically every
player can improve his result absolutely
yes we'll just get some final thoughts
from a Christian for a day two of the
Rapids over to you in Zagreb Christian
enough
thanks guys yeah and as you said the
mirror the tournament definitely doesn't
end and we've seen that displayed in
Poland when Magnus just scored I believe
plus 10 in the blitz portion to win that
event so absolutely anything can happen
definitely don't count the former world
champion out of contention just yet
there's still one uh day of Rapid a lot
of points at stake and I have to say I'm
impressed by a lot of players but
specifically nepo has been showing great
form today but also Fabi Fabi did really
well he started off shaky yesterday but
I have to say he's definitely picking up
the pace and how much confidence does
that Victory against Magnus Carson give
you
um I think yes I mean it's very
important victory for him and I'm also
I'm impressed with results especially
after talking about it in the morning at
the at the beginning of the rounds that
uh he was doing not so well I mean
suddenly he heard what I said and
started to win everything yes and
actually I spent two last rounds sitting
all the time in inside of the hall and
it was such a great atmosphere it was
really cool to see Magnus winning this
game against swishy it seemed that he
was actually bored about the position he
was kind of sleepy you know it seemed
like he will make this kind of quick
draw but suddenly you know step by step
he started like to wake up and at the
end you know I mean he managed to even
to crush the former world champion and I
think he it was very important victory
for him you know after losing two games
in a row I mean yeah I mean you really
need to do something after that actually
all chess fans left the plane venue
because Magnus he went there also and he
signed some autographs so he was in a
better mood but still I think it was a
good one I want to ask you about that
moment about when Magnus lost against
alireza and he just froze on top
unbelievable looking at the audience and
for a second I thought that he maybe is
insulted by the fact that they're
clapping or in but it didn't feel that
way I think he was just calculating
something I think yes he missed I felt
like he missed the smooth Queen and
Fades check and then he understood that
Queen F4 is not working and he just kind
of was stuck and it was happened so
quickly and he resigned so quickly that
he kind of needed this time to
understand what just happened I know
that he has this Habit to put all the
pieces back to the starting position but
he didn't do this at this moment he just
he was stuck for some seconds and then
he left the plane venue and I mean it
was very interesting moment and this
first time in my life I saw him like
that and it was really interesting so I
just want to say to our followers once
again if you want to see the video
because I was still recording at this
moment you can check our social media
accounts don't forget to subscribe to
um grantchester social media Instagram
Facebook and Twitter accounts and you
can see many many different materials
that there and watch the videos lots of
fun lots of action and lots of tension
from Zagreb Croatia and we'll be back to
give you all the insights from on-site
right here with around the seven eight
and nine if I'm not mistaken coming
shortly tomorrow see you guys tomorrow
you're not mistaken Christian Anastasia
thank you for the insight and for me too
Frozen uh
absolutely thank you all for joining us
and enjoying today we hope you'll tell
your friends and tell you tell them
where you're hanging out join us
tomorrow good night everyone thank you
and see you
[Music]
thank you
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited